two hello
it is a
summer Wednesday and it is hot
it's a hot day baby
welcome though
oh right
[Music]
get him out of here no
the apocalyptic prolapse
[Applause]
man this this is why I'm watching
[Music]
me
[Music]
talk about the allegations audio is
slightly delayed
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
perfect
[Music]
ly
[Applause]
yeah
wow
no oh God no more
no
you guys
no no
poor Garden
is this for voting his is he going to
heaven soon what does that mean oh
or is he going to hack
[Applause]
wow wow oh my God holy crap wow oh my
God what was it exhausted how long was
that one uh but two minutes and four
seconds so it's four seconds longer than
the last time yes
okay
that's one way to avoid swearing in the
first 30 seconds
holy smokes guys well well done
it's an off the rail Bonanza
for an off the rails
spectacular show today we have good news
and incredible content it's everything
you want and more
that's right that's right we don't have
sponsors though so I would like to say
that a real fast we have our Basics
collection coming out on Thursday at 10
A.M PST these are beautiful pieces man
you guys are going to love these just
perfect
classic pieces
I'm wearing one right now oh you are the
shirt I love those shirts I love this I
want everything from the store I love
those shirts man but the fleece is so
nice I'm telling you this is on another
level guys we have really
we have really ascended here
so that comes out on Thursday and also I
just want to acknowledge Olivia's
beautiful
uh peanuts
sweater which she is a rocking
um absolutely is that the women's one
Olivia it is yeah here it is
uh the women's crew neck and pink and
black or that's Navy too Olivia
Olivia
anyway so there it is thank you thank
you to everybody
where to begin
um there okay so obviously you guys see
the title
we destroyed triller and Roy Ryan
Kavanaugh dude decimated them
at one of the lawsuits but there's a
story in today's show
that absolutely has shocked all of us
yeah to the foundation we were just
talking about it
I honestly can't get I can't wait to get
to this
um
oh my God I think it's the craziest
thing I've heard on YouTube my jaw is on
the floor maybe ever yep so one of the
milk boys admitted in graphic details on
a podcast how he
how do I say this without getting
uh maybe save it he gratifies his dog
yeah I did not come on and this was in
like a Shane Dawson thing this is him
being like I do this and this is how I
do it and this is why I do it [ __ ] my
dog [ __ ] my dog I mean it's it's
absolutely Bonkers we're gonna get to
that afterwards but we've got a great
a whole great thing here thank you guys
welcome 200 bones right off the top from
Bella Simmons oh yo can I get a pride
minute
you know what
all right let's do a pro I mean it's
like it's not up to you that's what the
whole point of Pride minute is you don't
tell me when you get to experience Pride
all right it's up to me all right go
ahead we're already in Pride minute
guys welcome to Pride minute everybody
Embrace yourselves you are beautiful you
are worthy don't let anybody tell you
what is and what isn't the proper way
to be okay
Express Yourself be the person you were
born to be and feel pride in it
Society has come a long way and we don't
have to give in to bigotry
we don't have to give it to homophobia
or transphobia even which is now the new
hot thing we don't have to deal with
this [ __ ] anymore we are gonna rise up
Fists in the air
and say
that we will not be repressed
um has it been a due time a minute yeah
okay we're almost there just saying it's
a long minute
and you know I'm just saying be proud
live your true self and we we here at
day two podcast love and accept you
however you come how is that admit this
is the longest minute Dan oh my buzzer
isn't working well it's over cut it all
right back in the closet freaks Dan how
was that long that was like a 10 minute
minute
60 seconds my friend it was yeah
we got to reduce Pride minute it's got
to be 30 seconds it's too long these
freaks have too much time to celebrate
Pride back in the closet back to
conversion therapy with you I felt gay
you
back in the closet Foo Steve
absolutely disgusting shame on you all
remember when Pride was a sin yeah pride
is a sin you absolute animals
yeah Pride minute is a special special
time
but again it's not anyone who does a
rainbow now is being banned I'm just
telling you with peace and love now's
not the time
yeah can we get crosses in the chat
please for Jesus I've essentially been
banned guys Prime minutes over when he
crosses in the chat because we are godly
people and we fear God and we feared
homosexuals too
there's nothing scarier in life than
homosexuals they are coming for us
they're coming for our marriages
they are God is angry
kicks down crosses up
dicks down crosses up oh look at little
baby loving in the arms of yeah look at
that oh you're he's holding a lamb
what's Jesus care about a lamb there's
people dying bro I'm a man of God I'm
just gonna say keep the crosses coming
because you guys know about these floods
in Pakistan and these incredible heat
waves of China that's the Gay's fault
Amen brother
when when a man kisses another man a
Chinese dies amen
Amen brother
who do you think you are Amen brother
this Pride minute nonsense is over
because every minute you out in Pride
Jesus casts his damnation on You Frank
and SEMA is an idea I drink semen not
because I'm gay no
because milk
it's just another form of meal semen
tastes good now repent will get cancer
in the butthole right God damn it now
just because I take it now just because
I like to receive
Don't Make Me Gay
it's the holy spirit it's to prevent
prostate cancer all right you're gonna
see the power of God all right hey I've
seen Pride fights Bam Bam Bam
them out okay
mods mods come on
now I want to tell y'all something here
today
Jesus is watching you
don't be watching none of that
homosexual pornography I am furious even
if it rolls up accidentally and you're
recommended
don't be clicking that no the Temptation
the Temptation oh no oh no no no Jesus
clearly said
lay not down with your brother Lord
lest ye be having too much fun in it
[Music]
having so much fun you think I wouldn't
want to suck a fat juicy dick it's all I
think about Lord but I control myself
yes
the urge to suck a dick and kiss a man
sometimes you can overwhelm you amen
Lord
but we must resist the urge you're a
dick rider you're a dick sucker hop up
my [ __ ] dick all right thank you
Pride minute it's been a whole situation
here hasn't it folks
let's get right into it man we got so
much to cover here today so much
as you guys know
um
should I just talk about triller right
at the top or I mean
we've got some fun let's let's let's set
let's do some goose and gaps I mean
those are all great dubs though that's
like great dubs
what is this
is this yummy is this human it's uh you
just got to show you well it's another
kind of Mill it's not a kind of milk
yeah I know it's a pumpkin spice latte
why do you guys bring me this
because it's hot girl fall soon hot girl
fall yeah it's PSL day PSL My Guy what's
PSL pumpkin spice latte my friend it's a
day well it's the day they produce it
Starbucks they just brought it back or
whatever you know who loves pumpkin
spice and was hyped about today who Miss
Sam Samuel clearly she's all armed for
the teeth pumpkin spice
did everyone else get a pumpkin spice or
is this just a treat for the boss uh we
all got it
oh my God it's so sweet the day this
returns is the best day of the year is
it really okay yeah shout out love that
for you it came back yesterday wait is
it fall
yes Starbucks said yeah it is our boxes
sizes yeah Starbucks makes it does not
fall
no Ian
it's not time yet look at this [ __ ]
background we're in Fall Guys no cheers
it might be a hundred a thousand degrees
August and it's a 110 degrees September
tomorrow in August today
[Music]
it's fall stop whining dude look behind
me on your desk
why are you being a buzz girl how about
the [ __ ] my pants
September 22nd you know the [ __ ]
pumpkin spice bro that chair changed you
that's all I'm just gonna say it
sip it and then tell me it's not fall
it's disgusting the nectar of the God
I'm sure I don't like it either it's not
too sweet actually I love shopping you
said it was good before the show I did
not he did he was like that was before I
said this why are you fronting Dan you
don't have the lighting that was before
I had it true I was just going off a
memory I was like it's okay and now I'm
drinking at him no aunt had it before he
said it was good we like you don't have
to lie first to like you did
come I'm not lying crifter and if
anything this is just gonna get
everybody mad at me I'll be honest
though I like this situa I like the idea
of it but there's way too much sugar in
this is there any extras I'm already
done with mine you can have mine yeah
come grab them both if you really like
it you could always ask what about
milkshake ass [ __ ] you're drinking dump
it in your ice cam you can have mine
it's not even a coffee
his head whip on it I'm on a diet oh hey
Lena
[Music]
um
yeah go ahead take cam here enjoy it
please
yeah absolutely how you doing over there
good thank you I'm on it I'm actually
doing really good on my diet and those
things have like 10 000 calories I'm
pretty sure
so I agree sometimes I have a couple
tips yeah I like getting half the syrup
like half the pumps so it's like not as
sweet oh I think half of the pumpkin
flavor no the pump of sugar bro hater no
this the pumpkin is yeah it's like sugar
it's like a pumpkin flavored syrup oh
yeah and you still get the pumpkin
flavor but there's just it's not as but
less sweet that's strong no Dan I still
taste it I see what you're trying to do
and no no I think it's very interesting
that the biggest proponent of the
pumpkin spice latte [ __ ] in here is
saying she can't even handle a full dose
do not waste stuff
sometimes the sweet your pumpkin
lightweight all right guys enough enough
lightweight
change it back to summer thank you not
doing this now yeah we have too much to
get it's August thank you though
regardless Sam it was a nice thought
so you guys um
know that we love these Marvel edits
we're the horrible sound editing where
they cut it up and it's just a nightmare
Place one to remind the people this is
the first time for me in the Marvel
universe that is how they publish it
there's a finger before this character
to come back well
I just want to be clear we didn't edit
that that's how they published it do the
Obi-Wan again
this character to come back that one may
have or no the first time for me quite
edit
that one's my favorite the first time
for me that's uh Loki and this is the
first time for me in the Marvel Universe
hi my name is Aquafina and I am in the
movie that one's actually really good
so a new one dropped actually
um it's Tom Hanks in the new Pinocchio
trailer who does Tom Hanks play in the
Pinocchio Geppetto I imagine yeah
Geppetto he's not up for that
Geppetto is a the thing about Geppetto
is
he's trying to create a real boy
and when Pinocchio goes out on his own
he goes to Pleasure Island
he's trying to partake in all the
pleasures of the world
and when he gets turned into a donkey
who's it's like who really made the ass
of themselves why is it the donkey's ass
or the ass that's a good question
actually right exactly and and when
Simba fell from the Cliffside
we all wondered what does Geppetto think
about this Miss Jiminy Cricket
all right uh so anyway here is Tom Hanks
uh in
the new Pinocchio
the idea of taking on a treasured
classic as Disney's Pinocchio Disney
Pinocchio it's an incredibly Rich
opportunity to revisit and go deeper
into this Great Masterpiece and
refillable is it different they really
use these Pinocchio they tried so hard
to make hey let's let's listen again
carefully
the idea of taking on a treasured
classic as Disney's Pinocchio it's an
incredibly Rich opportunity to revisit
and go deeper go into this business
there's no way to say it like that go
deeper and go deeper there's such a
brutal cut there there's no breath
I disagree I don't think this is an
opportunity to go deeper it's Pinocchio
it's not that [ __ ] deep to begin with
and we've I it's covered territory at
this point how many Pinocchio movies are
there
there's like five coming out this year I
know who's gonna be I know who's going
to be front of the line though for that
one
Jordan Peterson well there's also the um
the Paulie Shore one what's coming out
he's voicing uh Pinocchio that already
came out oh that already came out yeah
do you not know about that oh my God
I'm Pinocchio buddy hold on you I think
watched the trailer yeah I thought at
one point I think I thought polyshort we
sent it in the chat I don't know if we
talked about on the show
buddy I'm totally a I'm totally a
Pinocchio bud can I go out on me
I want to be a real boy you know who
Marvel needs to hire is ninja to do
these trailers
because he could just say it all in one
syllable without messing up they don't
have to do that
thank you thank you
all right here we go
Paulie Shore
wait this does say 2022. is that just oh
we're gonna get claimed for showing a
trailer that's the worst it's like bro
I'm promoting your dumb [ __ ] movie
and you're gonna clean there's one line
in there that is makes the trailer where
he's like Dad it's believed by eyes your
name would be Pinocchio it's now yeah
father when can I leave to be on my own
are you [ __ ] me in the [ __ ]
what the hell that and also like that's
right there's multiple Pinocchio movies
in one year Tom Hanks come on you have
better opportunities than this uh
Guillermo del Toro is putting one out as
well no [ __ ] way huh stop it what's
with all the Pinocchio movies damn
cam sent the like to dislike ratio and
Discord let me hear Paulie Shore again
that's Pinocchio one sec when can I
leave to be on my own I've got the whole
world to see you are too special are you
[ __ ] serious right now
when can I leave to be on my own buddy
comments are turned off well I didn't
even know about this one
uh blizzard woofier mod just sent me
this apparently Drew Carey played
Geppetto in a Pinocchio yeah
and this is from last year
what's happening what what are they why
are they forcing Pinocchio on I'm so
sick of Pinocchio deeper maybe the world
the world like really needs to learn not
to lie right now so they're like we
gotta bust out like a lot of people more
relevant than ever that's interesting
here's the like this like apologize
[Laughter]
I've noticed them hiding the dislike
button hasn't really stopped people from
disliking at all yeah weird although you
don't see it so go deeper go deeper why
buddy I want to be a real boy buddy
oh [ __ ] okay well keep your eyes out for
the 20 Pinocchio movies coming up guys
maybe uh maybe we should do them oh I
think that's a good old idea now it's
great let's just join the pile
clearly it's cheap as hell to license it
it's an incredible Rich opportunity but
is it public domain that might be why
you get like a bajillion adaptations of
it well I know Winnie probably is didn't
Winnie the Pooh just become public
domain it did just become public domain
yeah the story has built a public domain
since 1940. yeah well there you go that
explains it yeah
it's been public domain since 1940. how
does that explain that how does that
explain it well just this in the sense
of that it's cheap to make a Pinocchio
movie yeah this year you know what I
mean oh I don't know why they're all
hitting at the same time yeah
but just in general why there's so many
adaptations so wait I can use ah God I
got to tell ELO we got to make some
Pinocchio Teddy fresh here I love to use
I love like ripping off IPS that are
like we don't have to license
we don't refer to it as ripping is it I
say that facetiously it's not like we
made a Winnie the Pooh shirt as soon as
it became public domain because it's so
dealt sure yeah usually have to pay
people a lot of money to use their IPs
and I'm like want this one not this one
but I don't even have to ask permission
okay so there's that also there's
another great scene you guys know we've
been obsessed with tiptoes
which is Gary Oldman playing a little
person in the role of a lifetime
um and the role of a lifetime I I joke
shout out to the fupa Trooper who put
this by the way uh in the subreddit pull
your mic closer path or snatch me that's
right really it's right up on me
uh so I had joked that Gary Oldman was
just walking around on his knees I
didn't actually think that's what he's
doing because it just seems like
kind of insane right they shoot a movie
like that
well somebody caught him in the scene
they forgot or missed it or just like
the scene that much
you could see this [ __ ] walking
on his knees bro watch this [ __ ]
bro you were walking on your knees oh no
that's not the role of a lifetime
holy [ __ ] this movie just continues
to shock me
oh that's such a good catch shout out to
the fupa Trooper who saw that
unbelievable
definitely just a slip up I thought they
had some more Advanced Techniques of
filming this uh hard-hitting movie than
Gary Oldman walking around on his knees
but in the role of a lifetime Gary
Oldman wearing knee pads
fantastic
and the what no role of a lifetime Zach
and then the role of a life I've been
playing it Gary Oldman I didn't hear it
interesting
yo so
our other mod Mega just sent me this
this is Jiminy Cricket in the Tom Hanks
uh Pinocchio
okay it's kind of [ __ ] terrifying
yeah
it looks too much like a
I'm not sure what to make of that he
looks too much like a creature like a
like a different creature he's not
supposed to be like a [ __ ] Cricket
you see what a cricket looks like
they're not cute they're nice uncanny
valley like mammal we want deeper we
Jiminy Cricket is supposed to be a
beloved [ __ ] dope ass dude he's
we love Jiminy Cricket
it's a dope ass dude he does some cool
[ __ ]
wait a bloodborne inspired Pinocchio
game
there's a Pinocchio game coming out
[Laughter]
the hell
oh
okay that looks fire I'm not gonna lie
lies of pee the lies of Pinocchio okay
why don't they just say Pinocchio it's
like dude come on
okay interesting stuff yeah we have a
mystery here in the office as well
Dan found a nail on himself he brought
it home and your girlfriend found it
right Dan it was it was on the floor of
our apartment A mysterious it was in
your apartment so why are you blaming us
I'm not blaming us but I was just
I don't wear your press on nails neither
does Ally so wait wait wait wait I
thought you found this in the office no
no this is the houses it was like stuck
to the back of my pants and it fell off
like I had sat on it okay so your shirt
was stuck to your pants
I don't know how else it would have
gotten home with me your backpack maybe
or on the backpack or something hold on
hold on how do you know it came home
with you
I don't know how else it would have
gotten into my apartment that's the only
explanation I don't have it I don't have
a side piece uh so but you don't oh you
guys don't live together you enough no
we no we do so why is this all on you
what about Ollie uh well she doesn't
wear press-ons personally but neither do
you right so that's
so there are multiple people that I work
with that do so that was where my mind
first went
so to defend myself well hold on we'll
get to that before the charges are
abroad
was uh was Ali suspicious of you when
she saw this I mean she was like kind of
joking like oh did you bring a girl
around here because Dan was kind of
freaking out in the group chat he was
like yo you guys are throwing me on the
bus here because all this I was being
all the ladies she wasn't really mad
it was more just a mystery well where
did the nail come from Dan are you
telling us everything that's a good
question
that's any question I'm afraid only you
have the answer to
again the only people that I interact
with that wear nails like this
work with me in this office so that that
was where my mind went all the ladies
provided pictures of their nails This
was um right and I didn't really know
why we were talking about this on the
show today because it was kind of
inconclusive and I was like well what
are we're just going to roast me and but
yes well
would anyone like to speak up because
apparently there are some strong
feelings about this hold on I'm not done
okay
okay you're not acquitted Dan well I'm
calling away this is a year this is I'm
calling a witness I'm not done do you
know what do you just sit sit and listen
um
this is Lena's Nails right yep yeah
those are mine nothing like the ones
yeah no I think she's in the question
this was uh Olivia Sam's or Sam's
looks a lot more similar some real uh
some real uh clenchers there huh some
real claws yes how long have you had
these ones on Sam they're super grown
out in that picture and I I just got
mine redone yesterday
uh they've been on for probably about a
month in that picture maybe a month a
month so that would obviously you
wouldn't be wearing
some random uh pull up a picture of it
just to compare
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
and Dan listen you got to just chill
okay
you're trying to influence the the jury
it's just outrageous what you're doing I
see what you're doing
look at this now okay
also how does a nail break off like that
seems kind of brutal the way it broke
off doesn't it
you would feel that right that's like a
brutal break I guess Dan the way that
that's true Jesus someone you're on
trial
shoot it off or stuck something under
the back Edge to get that off that's the
only way that that nail came off so
there's no way that the owner of this
nail
departed with it knowingly
unknowingly
okay so Sam's got these this is Olivia
you don't you don't do the Press ones at
all I did press-ons last week I have a
photo of what they were that's
interesting no no they're round and they
have french tips those show their
pictures I'm sending it right now
people came hard for me in the group
chat that's why I'm I need to you're the
only one that did press songs recently
that is a big flag it is however I'm I'm
proving my innocence
there's someone else in the album as
well well here let me take a look at uh
on the phone man these
no no no and I was in a show so every
time one of them fell off I would bring
it to the theater and repress it on
because you were in the show I was in a
play over the weekend I was like extra I
need my nails also the one that Dan
found didn't have so you had a nail fall
off during the show
no like if a nail were to fall off I
would save it and re-glue it and when's
the last time a nail fell off you're in
it happened
I'm sure it happened last week but
that's oh [ __ ] but it's not my nail well
so you claim so you say
but I don't know it's troubling
information
yeah I have to say the first person that
came to mind was Olivia just because
that's happened to her but the in the
original picture Dan sent it's just a
tip it's not like a full press-on nail
so that's just thank you Lena you're
right so um here it is this is the tip
and question pick tip no I don't think I
don't think it's a tip I think it's a
full nail it looks like a thumb moving
down this is Ela I mean come on we know
ELO's that's not elos you guys think
that's ELO's definitely not yeah those
are def the one that Dan found is
definitely a press on because whoever
had it on didn't file down you're
supposed to file down there's like a
tiny nub at the tip of so are you
suggesting that the nail that this
person belongs to is not good at doing
them they're not good at doing press
right now so that would be extra
interesting if it was your nail and the
glue was messy like whoa how did the
glue get like that at the bottom
so the perpetrator potentially could be
denying this out of embarrassment that
they're so bad at doing nails all the uh
chat is blaming Tana
can we pull up pictures during this okay
look when she was here her nails whoa
that's interesting
yeah but ela's never used press-on nails
now this is a Zack's hand I don't
believe I've seen exact use press on
nails have you Zacky uh no I have not
I'm surprised you didn't take a picture
with your Rolex on your wrist it was at
home it was it wasn't bad you know just
had a bath I'll just imagine you're
wearing a roll-up yeah
so Tana does do rectangular nails but
she does acrylics I think
um going down going down oh you said
there's a refresh I don't see it just
drop it in the chat oh some people are
pointing out the mods were here the
other week too right oh Ray Ray wait can
we get a shot of her nails we gotta Ray
I'm sure you're watching let's let's see
here hold on you just got called out by
Olivia if those Nails match
devastating
so I need a picture of raised nails and
I need a picture of Tana's Nails okay
because right now Olivia is not looking
good for you
you're kind of digging
digging what you're talking about you're
at the scene of the crime you've been
losing nails like crazy
everywhere you go
now she's like Olivia just be dropping
Nails right Olivia say that
yeah but it's acrylic so it's not her
she no no no those were pressons no that
looks like an acrylic tip because like
that was a good thing big tip it's the
first step when they do that hold the
tips on so so we're
worse is her or no
I'm saying no
not Olivia oh God whose nail is that
baby what the [ __ ] is that that's uh
that's Cameron
I'm not showing that that's terrific hey
come on take it easy hey this is not
your real foot stop dude come on yeah
it's making it way worse than what it is
what the [ __ ] about this it's Photoshop
yeah I know okay I Photoshopped it did
you want me to show your little [ __ ]
I threw that in the in the group chat as
a joke last night had I known it was
gonna be on the show I would have taken
my feet to the barber shop oh it wasn't
it was a b that sent it I see yeah
see man eat your heart out that's
definitely zero out of ten from cement
cam Grant stick what's your what's up
dude also Abe's losing his teeth
unrelated so so
it was my tooth
all right do we have any pictures of uh
so we're here we have Tana I'm trying to
find clearly not the same yeah not the
same at all so tennis it's not Tana yeah
it's not Tana what was the mod episode
called
uh
two Fridays two Fridays ago yeah yep
tip
people saying it's a song
I don't think he wears and he paints his
nails I mean or we are considering the
possibility Dan has a side piece
joke about that I don't need the [ __ ] in
the comments
I can see the Reddit thread already I
would never damn would never Dan's a
faithful man I will give him yeah Dan
would never
he's a man of God I would trust him with
my life giving me too much credit too
what because you would
no just having him to be able to juggle
multiple women yeah yeah Dan's a good
man listen I would if I could but I
can't that's not what I'm saying
Dan is a good man I would bet my life
that he would never be
but don't don't [ __ ] me do it but did we
check with chantali yet
oh Sean tall wear Nails she doesn't
usually not wear press-ons or acrylics
um she wears gel
okay we need a picture of Chantal and
Rey's Nails I'll move on for now but
this is a open open case raised nails
were black there were some that were
silver I thought so I but I think you
need to Grapple with the possibility
down that this did not come from our
office
okay I mean I could be wrong about that
I it's a natural assumption to make like
yeah Ally doesn't wear these I don't
wear them there's been no other women in
our apartment and there I work with a
bunch of people who do wear fake nails
so naturally that was the conclusion I
came to
see I thought you found it in the office
here's Ray's Nails I would completely
sitting on the ground of my kitchen Ray
did have some grayish nails but they're
not the same
they have like little dot on them the
nail in the picture is unpolished for
sure it's plastic it's a plastic tip and
I think it's a I don't think it's an
acrylic tip I think it's it's definitely
from a store
wow I would totally own it like the
donut thing I said I took off a piece of
that it's just it's so not mine we need
a picture of um people are saying Ally
has a side piece that's it
someone else is in that apartment
dropping Nails interesting you gotta ask
why are you automatically the one Under
Suspicion right that's a good point
that's a good point let's get her on the
call and ask her a few questions
thinking that Ally doesn't wear nails
like that no no she doesn't
thank you Dan for your patience and and
also for your cooperation this
investigation I mean I was the one that
brought this forward I want to point out
yeah well a lot of times serial killers
are the ones to report their credit
doesn't mean anything Dan's a good man
Dan is a good man people saying what
about Whitney she was here recently that
was a long time ago man
she knows she didn't sit on the couch I
don't think I think
right because it started shooting I
don't know that a hundred percent but we
were all after the show sitting on our
couch and my assumption was it was on
the couch and got stuck to my pants
I'm gonna move on as if you guys find
more compelling evidence bring it to my
attention okay okay
so this is an open case maybe the people
at home will connect the dots yeah how
do you
where we could they might actually
they're gonna see in the background of
an episode from like two months ago yeah
that's someone somebody's somebody
wearing nails if you know something say
something you see something say
something
this is just a great uh edit from much
dank
of ant Tate and the milk boys oh my God
I can't wait to talk about the milk boys
one of these guys jerked off his dog
straight the [ __ ] up bro that's like
Alpha [ __ ] these are alpha Bros they
jerk off their [ __ ] dog
by this
um anyway just this is just a a little
bit of enjoyment here from much days
morally cheat here's the thing you don't
really look I could sleep with thousands
of women I just think it's boring hurry
up yeah I'd rather [ __ ] dudes oh hell no
[ __ ] yes how does that work well I'm a
man of God I read the Bible I go to
church that's awesome but I also suck a
little bit of Dick whoa but this is why
God wants the the man the masculine
males of Earth through [ __ ] dudes oh
what Parable is that in shut up okay
who's doing anal for me because I'm the
bottom really which means I'm the one
getting plowed so God's looking down
right now and he's like boys I just want
you to run through boys yeah wow what
about have you ever dated a girl no
because men are women but better would
you ever date a girl never
bro no that's cat girls are disgusting
and they're smelly that is true that is
true I think uh girls shut the [ __ ] up
it's unattractive I'm surprised no
feminists have ever come for your neck
no no they've tried but how can you come
from my neck when my neck doesn't exist
right wow that's the game
wow I I'm still as perpetually shocked
that the elk boys have a successful show
I mean these guys literally
no
how did how is this happening where
these guys are somehow having
interesting conversations with people
that's the game that is the game okay
shout out thank you much dank [ __ ] yes
this was also should work for Disney
yeah
yeah cleaner edit in Pinocchio
also talking about the poppable which we
spoke about uh we actually tried last
week
to a lot of uh controversy
um I think overwhelming hatred of it
does Zach seem to like it I ate it all
so so whatever that means
do you still stand by the poppable Zach
of course yeah yeah of course of course
it's basically a pizza without the bread
so they just throw all the ingredients
into like a [ __ ] Tupperware and you
just go to town on it so I'm actually
really curious the report of the week uh
YouTube's Premier Food reviewer
put out a video called Papa John's New
Papa bowls are disgusting so I was
actually really curious to get his
thoughts on this because you know what
he says goes man yeah
that looks just like the one we got man
is it you know I don't know look I don't
want to judge a book by its cover here
all right but
I'll preface this by saying that
um it might be delicious it might be
quite good
based on what I see right in front of me
and based on what I smell because it's
very potent in terms of uh
in terms of the scent
it doesn't smell good at all I I'll say
that it smells um he's gone too far it
smelled like a pizza I mean you could
say it's gross but that [ __ ] smelled
okay
not great okay it reminded me of pizza
back me up people nobody all right Dad
I'll tell you that right now it's just
not an appetizing
I would describe it more as an odor as
opposed to a scent and looking at it
all right fine you know I'm just gonna
get it out of my system and I'm just
gonna say it just based on what I see
I imagine this being like
slop that's poured into a feeding trough
and you have like a bunch of hogs lined
up that's funny that's just eating it
that's just the imagery when I when I
when I look down and I see this and the
scent that that this emanates as well
which like I said is not good not
pleasant uh certainly not something that
you really
um
that would really get your appetite I
can't help but have that imagery let's
get to work either way yeah sure it
doesn't look that good and it doesn't
smell that good but maybe it tastes good
so we will find out we're just going to
try it out I'll let you know what it
tastes like definitely need a knife and
fork to consume it so have it right here
I've been editing out the eating
segments but I think it's a [ __ ]
pepperoni on turn concern how how easy
it is to consume this so I'm just gonna
keep this all in
the
what is what is this one the Italian
meat Trio
Papa bowl from Papa John's going in and
by the way officially
[Music]
um
uh uh
rebuked by Papa
I texted him during the show he says
abomination
he's right
for once he's right I love that he's
cutting it like a lasagna because that
thing is just
you're not you just tear into it man let
me finish that's just a pepperoni and a
sausage with cheese and sauce on it that
was the wet one you had yeah there was a
lot of moisture on the bottom which was
a bit alarming
oh he's going in for a second bite King
always always if that's he always goes
for the second bite yeah that's a staple
review bra that that's good that's got a
formula that's fair you know yep it
might even take a third
I feel like I'm getting sick again
watching this
oh yeah you you charged it I forgot and
puked pretending to feed you pizza's
actually buddy also I'm just giving a
close-up
all right
you loved it here we go a third bite oh
yep so this doesn't necessarily mean
that he loves it just that he's being
thorough
it's misleading it's very misleading
what do you mean like I don't know when
I had it it's like it's like so little
that you want a little more and you
can't tell if it's good or bad so you
keep going and going and then right you
can't tell right
right
so we're three bytes in
checking his notes
is he gonna go for a fourth bite
I mean usually he takes a while too he
takes his time yeah yeah well that's
good he's a professional Thumbs Up by
the way for review bro
wow
he's really sitting on it
drippy is he always this dripped out by
the way yes always
here's what I can discern
from it
all right here's what I can
tell so far there is definitely not any
sort of Base so at least what I got
there is no
um dough or any of that involved
whatsoever these are just
they took the sauce and the toppings and
dumped it into a plastic
bowl and that's what it is that's
exactly what it is
you can see that's [ __ ] close up bruh
that's what it kind of looks like as
you're kind of eating it and that's what
I was talking about with the liquid it
starts to pool and it it just yeah
unsavory does not begin to describe this
abomination of God
foreign
I wonder how many people are ordering
this you know I'd love to get the sales
stats on this
cross section
and uh
I understand if if you have
some serious
let's say health concerns and you just
can't eat any of the
Pizza whatsoever and you can't have any
any sort of bread or dough or any of
that
that's the one circumstance where I can
understand that
this might be one of those cases where
if you look at it that way all right
something is perhaps better than nothing
so that but that is the only
circumstance that I could understand
someone
really uh willingly eating this
in any other circumstance
I cannot find any justifiable reason for
getting this and I am very thankful that
along with this I also ordered a pizza
Legend because
this thing is uh
is going right in the trash
after the camera goes off
it's gross that's the only way I could
really describe it that Abu ate all that
you
you die yeah Anne
dude it was Thursday before and after we
come in early I didn't have breakfast I
was starving and I just went to town on
it
so bad dude look at all this [ __ ] on the
bottom
before after
I'm sorry I loved it okay Champion beers
true authentic self does Papa John's
crust really add that much if you like
what you put on the pizza then you'll
like this
starting to think the nail with Sam's it
no I'm just kidding I think it does I
think it does there's more like
it's more measured it's more like this
is just they dumped a bunch of [ __ ] and
the moisture on the bottom I don't know
but but I'm glad you like it it was good
people are saying I liked it I didn't I
was just doing [ __ ] okay stop it
I tried getting review Brown the podcast
a while ago but he doesn't travel uh
apparently to La very often
but there you have it so the poppable
ladies and gentlemen uh
shout out to review bra who has been a
consistent professional
for 11 years going my goodness oh look
at him he's just a little kid 11 years
this man that's adorable
who amongst us can say they've they've
stayed consistent for that long yeah his
suits uh are a better fit when he's like
13 than they are now it's giving me Bar
Mitzvah Torah portion
we love you review bro
you know he has a short wave radio show
no way yeah that's awesome it's so funny
all right I gotta get to a main story
there's so much [ __ ] here but I gotta
move on
and get to something good
although I do want to touch on this
Leonardo uh DiCaprio who we've talked
about on the show he has he doesn't date
women over 25.
and this has been kind of a meme there's
even grab like someone made a graph
about it
and I thought maybe this time would be
different because so many people are
talking about it
see here you can see a graph of all of
his girlfriends he's 24 all the way up
to 44's current or well this this is a
few months a few years old
because this girlfriend who he just
dumped was 21 at the time so this is
four years on now 21. he's 48 thank you
and when she when she it reached the age
limit of 25 they broke up
I don't I don't know what's going on Leo
I thought he would might actually make
an effort to break the seal the glass
ceiling as it were or even pretend to
and like wait a sec just she just turned
25 last month yeah
he's like that shit's too old you're
done Grandma I see you your frontal lobe
just finished developing you're no
longer interesting to me
um I wonder if Leo's a fresh and fit fan
yeah
how dare you I just find it like bro
just try a little I don't know I don't
like this because I like him as an actor
and a person but
I just find this a little odd man
don't you guys a little yeah no it's
weird as [ __ ] it's just a little it's
the pattern that's so bizarre
remember when him in dobrik teamed up at
least he hasn't dated anyone under 20
yet or I mean since he's been 18 or 24
you know what I mean so hopefully we
let's see you know we're eagerly
awaiting his next next girlfriend
quite a dating history though my
goodness
Giselle
bar Raphael
Blake Lively I don't know who Aaron has
heatherston is
or Tony Garin
or Kelly or Nina but these are just I
know they're the models
wait dobric and Leo collabs [ __ ] what
when
uh this was excuse me 2020.
hey guys I want to fly one of you to
hang out with me and Leo yeah right
you guys are gonna hang out
we want you and your friends to get out
there and vote okay I like that I like
Rock the vote Vibes all you have to do
is share this to your story tag a friend
in the comments and text five friends to
vote
was he paid to do this
is this a page thing
it got to be can you pay people to tell
people to vote that seems [ __ ] up
this is so weird
sometimes Leo looks super handsome and
sometimes he doesn't like this picture
this is not a good picture of him you
agree
I have to respectfully disagree you
think he looks great Sam here yeah I
think it looks at those eyes I mean he's
not showing his hair so
the beard situation is kind of wild
because it like goes he has a neck beard
kind of
ladies
not a great pick you give it to me or no
he looks like an older man to me an
older man no I'm not I'm not I don't
love this Leo like I mean he's almost
50. I think yeah he's way older
that's true he does look but he was hot
when he was young I think yeah I think
he looks good for his age yeah yo he has
55 million followers on Instagram
what is he doing just posting pictures
of Joe Biden he's very act Native
Americans and an environmental tiger I
mean what kind of Boomer [ __ ] is this
bro he's got a his own charity yeah
charity it's a environmental charity I
get it but why are you just post a
picture of a frog dude she's a frog come
on somebody help this man it's a frog
it's in danger probably he has 50
million followers he got 100 000 likes
we got to help him fire Mason cares
about the environment what a [ __ ]
loser what's the environment doesn't
matter if you don't get more likes you
gotta get more likes to help the
environment it's true you should post a
frog nobody would [ __ ] with me if I just
posted pictures of frogs you can get 10
likes
to turn the friggin frogs gay Jesus man
yeah we need Mason to help you with some
[ __ ] posts the [ __ ] is this thank you
Congress they already passed it
60 000 likes on 50 million
thank you Congress for passing historic
climate action okay it's done already
damn wait
that's why it's saying thank you I know
but like you don't have to post about it
no it's done I want to see him in like a
[ __ ] Speedo or some [ __ ] I want to
see him with his hot young girlfriend
you ain't gonna get that on Leo Graham
thank you Congress I mean what is this
just not how you get [ __ ] done if he
posted a picture of him at the beach and
then in between activism [ __ ] how much
of a bigger of impact we have if you
wrote like save the whales on his
titties or something just saying bro
exactly just saying
yeah get a hold of Mason Leo if you're
watching and you probably are reach out
to us I can help you
that being said I think all the ladies
of the office are over 25 is that right
or not you Olivia no I damn you're not
25 no I'm 24. oh my God okay so
okay Lena's over 25 that's good for you
maybe yeah
hold back okay so we have some uh young
ladies here for you too
you have a one more year on Sam and a
couple more in Olivia I know I'm
approaching my expiration date for you
yeah yeah yeah if you got one year to
make it happen Sam
I um
there's a gag just posted a picture of a
frog to the podcast Twitter
but I can't pull it up because the top
reply is currently a board ape sucking
its own dick wait I want to see that
send that to me
what do you think Apes do when they get
bored
they Auto fellatiate they Auto that's
called that there's a name for it it's
called auto fellatio right yeah well not
great yeah there's a depiction of it
right now all right don't show my screen
right now uh
oh my God bro what that's like super
like realistic pose
it's quite graphic
yeah it's just a monkey holding sucking
his own dick basically with a Halo on
it's like a little bit of Dick great
fantastic love that it's pretty cool
it's pretty I'd buy it I buy that nft I
bet it's an NFC already all right so
this is a this is better like if you
posted this at least it'd be more
interesting
Lisa's got his face on it
like yo we got to save these frogs y'all
[Music]
right
now this is a post
I don't know
I like the one with the frog face better
I think
of course you do Dan
I like the ape sucking his dick
let's just retweet that on the podcast
right now
all right let's get to this big uh milk
story and then we'll talk about the
trailer lawsuit
this is the I don't know what to say
about this story but basically
I came across this clip on the subreddit
at about 3 A.M last night
it had very little views on it and when
I first saw it I was
I thought for sure it had to be like an
edit or something or some kind that's
what I thought as well
some kind of gag right and I was like
what do you guys see this like is this
real I sent it in the Podcast chat we
have
and we've confirmed that it is all real
man and I mean
what's incredible about it Steve will do
it is is the person that in question
here who he was recently permanently
banned
from YouTube we don't know exactly why
but I think it's just gambling [ __ ]
steak it has to be
or actually he shared YouTube's
explanation what do YouTube saying
basically they just said that he
continued to break Community guidelines
they weren't really specific yeah from
what I gathered too is that he had
videos removed like probably got a
strike and they were removed and he
re-uploaded them to an alternate Channel
which is a big No-No so dumb yeah that
is so dumb
it's literally the dumbest thing I've
ever heard
well he's not a bright guy so it doesn't
surprise me
he also put out a bounty I don't know
what the [ __ ] this is my friend put this
out I this man is so dumb I mean what
the [ __ ] bro 250
000.
I will donate 250 000 to a charity of
YouTube's choice if they unban them are
you stupid
I'm just spitting facts do you really
[ __ ] think that
no it's this is just virtue signaling
right
of course YouTube's not going to take
that
four-day profile pic
it's a Vibe right now
I mean it's just the dumbest [ __ ] I've
ever heard
worst and then also he listen
do you have the picture of him saying L
on my I'm getting that right now yeah
he also poked the bear a little bit with
me because
when I posted a picture of me and Tim
Dylan
which by the way was such a or no he
posted a picture of us
I loved him some of his fans are demons
bro they are [ __ ] wretched uh
a lot of manosphere crossover
interestingly
a lot of people calling me fat and gay
which was interesting like a derogatory
because Tim is
both those things gay and beautiful
well he's a big boy like me he won't
deny it
but that one of the top comments was
Steve will do it saying l so it's like
okay [ __ ] boy
who's got DL now no Channel haven't put
a piece of crap I was going to say [ __ ]
but I don't I don't think he even
there's no reason to put down [ __ ]
right
you know trying to lean away from saying
[ __ ]
and [ __ ] too there's no reason for it
why why do we gotta put down [ __ ]
gotta put it put it on a pedestal we
don't put it on a pedestal but we don't
got to put it down either
just let it be
C sea level ground here just a nice
healthy yeah sea level [ __ ]
yeah exactly not below not about because
you go below you flood the [ __ ] No
Death Valley you don't want that yeah
you dry out the [ __ ] you don't want
that Himalayan [ __ ]
we did a nice well-regulated
also Colorado's a no-go too way up the
Buffs and the Rockies yeah oh hell no no
Rocky you get dried out it's not good
I think you're all misogynistic
why
I'm just kidding why would you even joke
about that because the camera cut to Sam
in the comments they're saying that well
how can you how could you say a
misogynistic I'm doing I'm trying to
change the world for better for women we
don't want that dry oozy
now when you say it that's where it
works that's a thousand times worse than
anything why would you say that's
horrific I mean Lena come get yourself
uh it's gross Jesus Christ David you
just went too far
I'm just saying I like a well-regulated
sea level I like my [ __ ] like I like my
militias bro well regularly yeah yeah
yeah exactly the where the right to bear
[ __ ]
[ __ ] Second Amendment
so I'm not saying [ __ ] anymore okay
that's that I'm trying my best [ __ ] so
here is um
Bradley Martin who we were trying to
squash the beef with I have no problem
with Bradley Martin
he has a podcast
and Steve will do it to his boy now what
shocks me about this
is that they didn't edit I mean this
isn't a live show they [ __ ] he put
this up my God how could you do your
friend like that you should have cut
this out this is
I can't believe they didn't cut this
what were they did he must have not I
mean he knew this was [ __ ] insane he
even was like what are you saying right
now
but Bradley put it up man and that's
what it is
laughs
uh Olivia has an update she says it's
okay
Olivia oh this is interesting Olivia
bringing some receipts okay I will speak
after we look at this who's Lilith
dumbass [ __ ] 666. oh it's a fan page
messaged me and said oh that's their
username
Dan took is of the acrylic tips that
they have only ER at nail salons and
those are not press-ons
and that is what that is so I will say
this Olivia and you know I love you
what's up your need to defend yourself
no no constantly is making me think it's
only because it was a joke between Sam
and I that my nails were popping off and
so I knew as soon as I saw that also I
said it from the beginning Olivia and
Amy leave her alone
this is interesting
this is interesting Intel this is useful
this is good enough thank you thank you
by the way that is it doesn't even it's
not even it doesn't go down to the nail
bed thank you by the way too dumbass
[ __ ]
this is very interesting I don't know
what to tell but what does this mean I
think Dan you gotta look outside
the office yeah I mean everybody's in
the in the clear I think you need to go
back to Ali and ask him a hard question
I think it's weird to see a just an
acrylic tip with no acrylic on it no
polish
I don't know I don't know I'm I'm lost
to me it didn't look like
a tip it looked like uh well no if you
look down at the bottom it's I gotta pee
you guys can debate but like I don't
know
can we see the picture of the nail again
yeah pull it up next to that uh give me
a sec
at the top roll it well
from the store have the little yeah but
these are also rectangular all right
here it is
AB you know nothing about Nails yeah no
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I really I just don't think it's
yeah honestly after hearing all this
information I'm not sure love go ahead
oh my God I I feel a bit bad because I'm
on a delay and I can't interject
naturally but I was thinking is there a
possibility one of those were on the
share of a nail salon and someone sat on
it and it got stuck to the pants and
then someone went to the office yeah you
know what I mean
after hearing all this info yeah I don't
think it was in the office seen the
group chat last night
I I felt like Sam was the most innocent
um thank you baby you're welcome and I
feel like there's some people pointing
fingers at Sam and it made me wonder
why they were so accusatory to Sam
because I don't even know [ __ ] about
nails but I know Sam's Nails never look
like that and they're always done up so
just saying thank you
you're welcome
this is less fun but it could just be
something really mundane like I stepped
on it and it stuck to the bottom of my
shoe and are you [ __ ] cheating on
Haley
Dan is uncorruptable in any way shape or
form it'd be pretty lame if it was just
like I mean that was caught it out I
know that that's kind of a mundane
explanation but it's probably true yeah
but we're having fun with it yeah
by the way uh unrelated but just since
Ethan's gone shout out to all of the
audio engineers in our audience of which
there are dozens apparently because they
all emailed me after yesterday's show or
Monday's show to uh offer some help on
troubleshooting the issue and um I
didn't get back to all of you because
there was just a lot and frankly
everybody was basically suggesting the
same handful of things but uh Zach and I
spent I don't know like four hours
working on it yesterday and we did see
some Market Improvement it's not totally
solved you may still hear an occasional
pop but it is uh working a lot better
now so thank you thank you shout out all
the eight did you guys make any progress
on the nail thing are we just is that
still an opening question it's still
kind of an open question of love
throughout a theory that is a lot less
fun but go ahead maybe plausible that
it's just something really mundane like
it was on the bottom of my shoe or
something or somebody accidentally was
picked it up
on the bottom of my shoe there's no way
I don't know I mean
nope okay fair enough there's something
deeper Happening Here hmm
I'm sure of it
talking about deeper though back to
um Steve will do it I've set this up uh
so Bradley Martin's about to get raw
and uh well Steve will do it's Dick's
about to get raw too
or Steve will do its dog's dick is about
to go through thank you Lina cheers
honestly I miss my ex-girlfriend's dogs
I missed I swear I really miss that dude
that's the thing oh dude when we broke
up we broke up for eight months or is
that how I started telling her how to
start messing Donald on Instagram I
really miss her dogs man what did he
just say mumble
he doesn't he seems a little bit uh
intoxicated that is my yeah something is
going on here I think he I mean he is an
alcoholic so maybe he's just drunk
man
but here let's continue on
um our dog start is like is he's
recently he's been like you come home
and there's just come everywhere what
are you talking about I put him over the
couches
until you see it you see the comp yeah
usually come stains in his dick is like
all big and throbbing so like it sucks
but like okay dude stop right there just
don't describe your dog's dick as big
and throbbing that's already a problem
am I right
correct I did not come on my dog I don't
like the words he's choosing already no
can you pull up a picture of his dog I
want to show the people oh my God they
have a board ape Happy Days
oh no these guys are such a mess
I can't help them
let me see a picture of his dog please
so you guys can uh yeah now he says
there's come everywhere
now I own dogs I've never seen dog calm
on anything
well your puppies are neutered right
well Shredder wasn't for a long time he
used to hump the [ __ ] out yeah
before they were neutered I never
saw anything I don't like that same on
my end too Shredder's probably about the
same size of this dog
he he used to have a stuffed animal that
he humped and got it all out before he
was neutered because we waited until he
was like two before we neutered him
sometimes there'd be like a drop of
moisture but I wasn't sure if it was
from his mouth because he would bite it
or if it was I but it wasn't like there
was to say there's come everywhere it's
kind of there's just no way this dog is
like seven pounds from everywhere in my
room
okay okay dude so let's let's continue
on with this this is like kind of crazy
I'm saying this but stop it one there he
goes this is crazy I'm saying it stop
stop back it up
don't say it Steve
oh start is like is he's recently he's
been like you come home and there's just
come everywhere what are you talking
about I put them over the couches
and you see it you see the come on yeah
usually come stains and then his dick is
like all big and throbbing so stop it
that's no good like it sucks but like
this is like kind of crazy I'm saying
this but one I'm the cool dad now okay
I'm the favorite you're the favorite of
the Bradley's like please God don't do
this where are you going where are you
going with those Bradley look how
stressed out he looks don't do this bro
understandable
and two you can control where the [ __ ]
goes what are you talking about bro
don't be doing this Bradley's like don't
say that [ __ ] you talking about I don't
like where this is going
the cool dad because you jerk them off
bro that ain't no cool dad [ __ ] that's
that's incest that's
you know what I mean ain't no cold dad
jerking you off that ain't right coming
what
hey how do you do this
so I get IVs all the time yeah yeah I
know you only wear gloves yes so what is
he what did he say I get IVs all the
time because nurses wear gloves right
yeah why is that of course they do
well this is where he got the idea
apparently of course they wear gloves
when they give you an eye yeah never
seen gloves before yeah I mean but all
medical professionals wear gloves when
he was getting his hangover IV he was
like yo plastic over your hand I could
touch my dog's dick with this dude
they're injecting something into your
blood stream of course they wear gloves
lately I've been just like groceries to
go you put on the glove and he said
Donald he's going on his stomach or like
on his number right here or like you go
couch look at that he's like please God
please bro do not be doing what I think
you're doing right now
which is which again is why it's so
interesting that he didn't edit it out
um yeah
that's that's just what keeps blowing up
they're sick of Steve
like this will torpedo him
usually just play like uh like uh like I
like cartoon like Disney like family
friendly and [ __ ] uh family friendly has
been uh
jerking off Donnie jerking your dog off
and the fact that he puts on Disney
makes this weirder right like the man
he has the time to get into a Disney
movie because that's a commitment right
so yeah he's Pinocchio he has enough
time to get into it
he's supposed to like keeping the
content Elementary for his child that he
is jerking off right he's the cool dad
he's a cool dad is he putting on lady in
the [ __ ] for the dog yo we should
figure that out cool dad Stevie and the
Beast
by the way people are wondering if he's
wearing like a bite in 2024 with the pr
I mean he's wearing it ironically he's
funny
he's a funny guy ironically
conservatives have this insane strum or
like hyperbole I didn't say hyper like
she's insane they say what's next we're
letting gay people get married what's
next people marrying animals
that's the conservative talking point
right meanwhile this man's wearing a
pride flag jerking off his dog so and
he's my goal all the way yeah what's
going on here Scooby Dooby Doo
people are saying this is actually
insane yeah I'm just we weren't
exaggerating when we said we were blown
away this morning and nobody's talking
about this what just came out this is
brand new this came out yesterday yeah
it's been out a full day
and even the comments are kind of like
not mentioning at that this is this is
revolutionary [ __ ]
this is changing the game forever
so his dog is laying on his back he's
got a glove on he's watching uh [ __ ]
lady in the [ __ ] and he's jerking off
his dog I mean have you seen a dog's
erection it's like it's I wouldn't he
just what well from you know South Park
that episode with the red rocket you
know
that's you know isn't that like it yeah
like lipstick oh no
oh this is cool cool dad
romantic trip to the moon this is
actually a uh the continuation of Air
Bud ladies and gentlemen this is Air Bud
part two he's a cool dad he's not he's a
cool dad but he's also a happy Dad oh
yeah
wow
somebody's oh my God somebody in the
comments said uh semen is another kind
of milk oh
good one semen is
today he said if you're super popular
and are not a family-friendly robot you
are eligible to get canceled for any
reason they will make up the reason
can you just reply from the podcast and
say why do you jerk off your dog
I uh bro I don't I don't know man I
don't think I even want to say that he
he did not come on my door he's gonna
have to answer this he doesn't need me
leaving comments
this is what he's this is his face when
his dog comes
I did not put my dick anywhere near my
dog
you know look at his pin tweet it says
my main Channel doc got deleted when I
have zero strikes and
I'm sorry it's blocked I'm reading off
your screen and my main mission is
helping people in need that sounds like
someone else we know who got banned
it seems to be the go-to excuse who said
that Tate
yeah exactly it's like bro I gave some
money out to some shout out to homeless
people
nothing says you can you can stop you
have to stop doing that my neck doesn't
exist the only people I see you helping
is dogs come
you care more about dog if you cared so
much about people why aren't you jerking
them off
big fan of Tom of Tom and burp for some
reason there too
okay uh so and we're just getting
started here folks
um
all right buckle up guys this is a full
send moment
that's this is a full dog full send
oh for sure yeah a walk walking your dog
half cent feeding your dog half sand
yeah making your dog bust a load full
scent baby full load full sun moon full
send to hell and you just gotta
appreciate these milk boys they're just
so Macho Bros and
what's more Macho broey than jerking
your dog off with a glove or watching
lady in the [ __ ] I'm gonna send it
full send baby
full seed
I'm gonna rip a load
my seeds all over the place go rip a
load okay so um
wait wait wait wait hold on so you're
telling me right now that you've been
jerking your dog off and so he doesn't
cool dad no yeah and and these are the
Macho guys bro you can't be giving them
you can't
yes dude that's exactly what he said man
I don't know what to tell you bro
there's it might sound crazy but it's
strictly business
um okay
it's very and kind of watch something
occupy myself and it's more of just a
what he does it to occupy himself I said
I watch something to occupy myself so
how long is he jerking his dog off he
might go he might let you know in a
minute here it's more of a little
workout but the thing is like dude I'm
the cool dad because imagine if you
couldn't jerk off and I was like what
the [ __ ] do I do he comes by like
[ __ ] a pillow
you know that's his normal that's his
normal move Bradley
this is where you turn off the camera
and you'll be like Doug we're homies
right
don't don't also this was I'll put this
out I don't think a live podcast
no it wasn't that's my point so like bro
come on I could have cut this out he was
he like nah bro just leave it in man
he's like dog plea Bradley if you were a
homie you would have cut the camera and
been like the unless you want to retake
that
oh my goodness do yeah but imagine
imagine you trying to come by like
[ __ ] a pillow like it's probably like
hard yeah dude why are you what let the
dog come how they come
they don't have hands they did they got
he's got no problem bro
he'll hump up he'll give him a stuffed
animal he'll hump it
he doesn't need to jerk him off I
promise like no no shoddies or anything
that's a full send my dude
wow
he goes he literally was like I feel so
bad for my dog he can't jerk off let me
jerk him off what
bro's gotta jerk off man let the dog
figure it out Saturday's for stroking
Saturday's for the boys they're eating
your meat
I just
I can't imagine
some people are saying
it's a troll what about this is a troll
there's no [ __ ] way this yeah and
even if it was what's what's funny about
this that's disgusting either way
yeah what kind of troll is you being the
guy who jerks off a dog why would you
want to be a joke about that Shane
Dawson used that as an excuse and it
still didn't absolve him it was like it
was a joke I'd never jerk to off my I've
never calmed on my cat I've never jerked
off on my cat I've never [ __ ] my dog I
did not come on my door like bad idea if
it was a clown anyway he'll for sure say
that he was
kidding or something but he's not
kidding the Joe Budden defense right Joe
but wait what did Joe Budden say
Joe Budden basically said the same thing
right he jerks his dog off I believe so
right yeah yeah there you go wow
following in his footsteps well hold on
hold the phone is there a lot of people
jerking their dogs off that's exactly
what I was just thinking can we do a
poll I mean
is this a thing guys
I I just wanted Paul have you ever
tricked off your dog
is that yeah yeah do you jerk your dog
off yes or no I mean sure that's two
people yes no I'm just saying animals
have their own culture they have their
own way of of gratifying themselves you
don't need to worry about
how your dog jerks off
he's an empath I think is the problem
so I mean eight percent say yes and that
can't I think these people are just
having a laugh in it
yes you're British obviously you said in
it like three times today where are you
picking that up from I like it
in it
Ian approves you see that he's like a
proud dad right there that's not your ID
he's the cool dad I'm the cool dad now
get your votes and folks do you jerk off
your dog
let the world know
are you a cool dad yes or no
there's no way nine percent I think
people are just [ __ ] around
yeah
people are not jerking their dogs off
okay despite what Joe Budden and
Steve will do it
that's a blowout pretty much a doggy
[ __ ] blowout Steve will Jerk It here's
Joe Budden admitted
and this was a huge Scandal by the way
it's a girl we're just using slurs don't
worry about it why do I always want to
make the dog feel good by playing with
their [ __ ] privates oh he was jerking
as
his female dog off
dude what is wrong with these people man
stop what
yeah
stop raping my dog it's not even his dog
it's not even his dog
the man came to someone else's house let
it play out with me real animal uh lover
because I don't play with my pets
anybody with a pet you come on you did a
little something down there manage dark
field
oh my God all right RH NBR
that's how normal it is to him is that
he's like he's like come on guys we've
all done it everyone like it's like it's
like picking your nose or something yeah
come on you've all picked your nose I do
it to everyone come on you've gone down
on your dog before
Jesus Christ I do it with everyone there
you go thank you Andrew
so you just come from a place of like
loving your animal wanting them to feel
good what about what happened to back
scratches yeah I couldn't tell you where
it comes from that is so [ __ ] weird
whatever whatever happened to belly rubs
take them to the dog park Rawhide
there's lots of ways to show your dog
you love them that don't involve you
jerking them off just the right height
no bucket is required anyway uh back to
Steve we'll do it
man this is we're learning a lot what is
it that he's doing you don't want to
know yeah it's probably not who who uh
his name is Steve will do it it sounded
like Joe Budden was fingering
oh the [ __ ] dog
someone else's dog on his couch during
the show cool
there's some [ __ ] we say on the show
where I'm like no one else is has said
this sentence on the internet
apparently kalila used to jerk off a dog
too so I don't know if this is a thing
or what and you know I love kalila what
whatever no but I'm just this is for the
uh this is just for uh
just for the record
we got to get all the information on
this they have Rudders I'm getting milk
I used to jerk off dogs a lot
but this is an unknown thing
yeah come on man I believe it I know I
believe it but I don't want to hear it
well dude that's code that's just the
original coconut water
[Laughter]
that's a joke
let's just say it's a joke let's hope
yeah let's just give her the benefit of
the doubt here
yeah
damn
[ __ ] me dude
all right then
back with Steve will do it
the best but then imagine you had
someone to come in and go help you out
yeah and then honestly that's [ __ ]
that's dope of you bro gross no what are
you doing don't
he goes yeah I jerk off my dog that's
dope bro honestly full send
that's kind of dope you can't really be
saying this bro you should be stomping
the recording there's a reason his Gym's
called the zoo
is it called the zoo yeah love that
jerking off Donnie jerking your dog off
I swear that's wait wait wait wait wait
hold on so you're telling me right now
that you've been jerking your dog off
and so he doesn't cool dad no there's it
might sound crazy but it's strictly
business okay
it's very and kind of I watch something
to occupy myself and it's more of just a
it's more of a little workout but the
thing is like dude I'm the cool dad
because imagine if you couldn't jerk off
and like I was like what the [ __ ] do I
do he comes by like [ __ ] a pillow
you know watch this man try to say he's
trolling hell no
that's his normal that's his normal move
do yeah but imagine imagine you trying
to come by like [ __ ] a pillow like
it's probably like hard you're not a dog
you're not a dog
why are you thinking about doggy
masturbation so much it's probably not
the best but then imagine you had
someone come in and go help you out yeah
and then honestly that's [ __ ] that's
Dopey bro right Brad
Dy my boy
dude if I can't jerk off my father's the
last person in the universe hey son hey
son you need a hand
you're I'm the cold dad now
yeah
stop it
there's plenty of reasons I gotta
control where the [ __ ] goes okay and I
feel like he likes me better than he
likes me way better than Selena now yeah
no [ __ ]
he controls where the [ __ ] goes he's a
[ __ ] Bender
what's he do with the [ __ ] does he say
um pre-workout
I'm the cool dad dude I'll be honest I
didn't see this conversation going that
way but I was I kind of like it's crazy
I kind of respect it Bradley's what are
you saying
[Music]
These Guys these are not Alphas this guy
just said he's cool with this dude
jerking off his dog
I mean dude if you couldn't jerk off I'm
I'm trying to put myself in that
position and it's like Donnie can't go
to the rub and tug no yeah he can't
there's no dog hookers damn bro it's
like bro you just got your Mom and Dad
mom's not cool you don't have a girl you
don't have girl dogs to [ __ ] no girls
but Frenchies can't [ __ ] but what really
fact check me here yeah I don't know
anything about Facebook or meta is this
is this misinformation it could be Ken
Frenchies not have sex that doesn't make
too much sense to me they go on to say
that they fact-tracked it and I guess
that is true for like purebred Frenchies
they have to artificially inseminate
them oh don't miss you that's what they
say in this episode it's coming up in
just a few can we can we cross fact
check that please
I don't know this could actually be
misinformation is this mentioned okay
because I think they can [ __ ] because
that's how you get more of them I know
but Frenchies apparently Frenchies can
breed naturally but it's very rare and
unlikely due to their physical
limitations
that dog should not exist man apparently
not
so how do they get made then they made
no [ __ ] lab I don't know they I don't
know are you dumb you're so dumb bro
how do they get made though
they're both so unbelievably dumb
seriously I know and I'm sorry Brad I
wanted to be cool but like again how is
this watchable content
how's this oh well this is great when
he's talking about jerking off his dog
don't get me wrong how does breeding
work bro
look at those thighs dude
Jesus could you wear smaller pads
that's gnarly as [ __ ] can we get some
longer pants on Bradley those are some
ball plots from this angle it looks like
a thong
Bradley power is not stopped falling out
and also as Dan pointed out before just
the dick angles like you would think if
this is the camera is there you wouldn't
be opening your massive
Gates Brad can we get like a [ __ ] can
we get a modesty blanket or something
I don't know I kind of changed my mind
he is pretty helpful by sitting like
that no it's Alpha as [ __ ] I can't deny
it yeah I have the balls too looks like
he wants a nice [ __ ] it looks like he
wants to get jerked off man like yeah
what are you waiting for Steve get on
over here get the gloves you can be my
cool dad
foreign
just the right height no gloves required
no glove No Love
they I'm pretty sure you're the same
thing spamming debate Brad in the chat
debate them on what
you're saying bait masturbate Brad yeah
Brad is it is it actually kind of cool
to jerk off your dog or no
let's let's have a debate debate
back how are dogs made if they can't
have sex
I can explain it to him I don't know if
it's a debate right all right Todd Riley
sometimes uh
fertility can or maybe that's too big a
word
Brad sometimes the natural means
can be a little difficult
and so you have to take
the liquid from the boy
[Music]
and you put it in a turkey baster you
know what that is
you know on Thanksgiving you get the
tube and you suck up the juice and you
put it on the turkey to keep it moist
foreign
you fill that up with you know your man
liquid twice everything nice
and you put it up into the vagina
and you just uh basting the so
I don't think he would understand that
stop the music please stop I must say
that I've had some post-coital regrets
about that phrase
you think he pops a wood when he does it
though you think it turns him on at all
he said it was all business yeah I'm
sure he did that's what he said Disney
movies jerking your dog off
like do you think it at least moved you
know what I mean
I I don't want to think about it think
about it Dan unfortunately tell me nope
I picture it I'm gonna distract my mind
with this pumpkin spice [ __ ] I think
there there might be a situation
or maybe some substances were involved
where he Coulda maybe you ever get drunk
and jerk off your dog Zack no
maybe not
but then again I'm not Steve old Yankee
you know
[Music]
he will yank it
oh no oh oh no Steve no it's right you
just got your channel banned bro you
can't deal with this level of
controversy now you're the Steve will
yank it
oh [ __ ] yeah the nurses were oh interest
oh you take it they put the baby into
the dog for example when I this man is
[ __ ] literally
oh he's like a rock with arms and legs
we're trying
I can't help it the Mana is [ __ ] dumb
he I'm sorry dude it's like all the
blood goes to his thigh yeah I was gonna
say he has other attributes he has other
actions he has giant thighs yes
IVs you know the nurses were oh intro oh
you take it they put the baby into the
dog for example they put the baby into
the dog
bro
extremely loose sense it's not that
complicated you put the semen in the
vagina that's it no that's like extra
pro-choice I bet it's already a baby
where'd the baby come from it's already
a bread it's already baby where'd the
baby go you put the baby in the dog
foreign
if I I'm wearing the glove already so
I'm getting too comfortable now because
Bradley enabled him he's like that's
cool I respect it now he's just straight
up when I jerk off Donnie
you go to now you now you got your guard
look at this face
when you're when your friend tells you
they jerk off their dog
oh [ __ ] I'm sorry Brad I know you hate
me already but
what can I do man
what can I do give me no choice
you didn't have to post it Bud oh I wish
you didn't I really did I didn't want to
have to talk about this nothing
uh finger scoop to come like like
you know and so why is he so descriptive
wait hold on I actually I I got so
Disturbed I tried to pause it and I
clicked off this man just said finger
scoop the [ __ ] why is he so descriptive
with it
you know and he's enjoying it and
Bradley's defense he may have been
thinking it's a troll I mean it's still
weird either way but I think at this
moment there's no denying it so to see
his reaction after this
I think we'll tell all
thank you love did you see that
yeah well what's interesting he did
employ a really good interviewing
technique which is to make them feel
comfortable so that they express more
right but actually I think that's just
from
I think you know that's from another
school of thought which is the um
vegetative vegetative state of
interviewing
um Louis Thoreau calls it radical
listening I call what Bradley does
vegetative state listening
vegetative state ladies and gentlemen
oh but Frenchies apparently can't I
don't know so how do they get made then
they made enough I don't know they I
don't know I think they pretty sure same
thing you need IVs the nurses were oh
intro they're supposed to confuse you
get pregnant with an IV I didn't even
catch that yeah no you don't injectors
[Laughter]
it do you guys reproduct this
reproduction this is like the basic
stuff like fifth grade Lord
oh my God that is mind-blowing this man
thinks you inject semen into your veins
to get pregged and then Bradley's like a
full baby goes inside right people I've
heard about that before
my Frenchy stud I breed goes to a clinic
to do the uh breeding a professional vet
does the breeding I can't imagine doing
that to my baby yeah well you're not the
cool dad and that's why you're not the
cool dad and you'll never be Amanda
thank you for the donut thank you for
joining
man
oh you take it they put the baby into
the dog for example when I jerk off
Donnie if I that's a sound bite
that grab that I'll pull that yeah
that's important and the glove already
so I what I do is you just uh finger
scoop to come like like uh like bro you
can't you can't say that
and also Brad you can't act like you
didn't just hear your boy say he finger
coops his dog finger Scoops his Dogs
come out
you can't
you have quick research it should say
dialing 9-1-1
dipping sauce
he just said dipping sauce I'm going
back Donnie if I I'm wearing the glove
already so I what I do is you just uh
finger scoop to come like like uh like
he's dipping sauce
Chick-fil-A sauce
finger scoop that come like dipping
sauce I have to pause every word the
process Sam how are you feeling at this
moment you look shocked not dipping
sauce oh my God I hate that sometimes I
use the chicken nugget to scoop it out
actually instead of my fingers easy
cleanup
[ __ ] Fried Chicken when you when you
eat bro I feel sick I'm gonna lie
I scoop it out with a Nuggie and then
it's easy cleanup
is the vehicle and then Bradley goes
that's cool bro I get that
and then you just [ __ ] you just put
it in uh bro you're right you did you
did how the [ __ ] did you know this I
have a Frenchie what the how do you know
stuff
I do know things bro
like you know how like how do you know
about putting semen in the bloodstream
that's great that's incredible are you a
vet
[ __ ] this is weird as [ __ ] but I think
you just put your finger inside them you
so you get to come and you stick it in
them that's how they do it or uh bro
these are some freaky ass dogs is this
really surprised by how fertility works
they do that to humans too you know
no way might be how you were conceived
for all I know
or a squeezer you squeeze it inside them
I bet like a dropper but I guess organic
would be um bro imagine if that's how
you had to get a girl pregnant like if
you couldn't dude it happens all the
time bro like literally oh how what who
are these guys also it's supposed to
mimic what actually happens when you
have sex yeah like what is so you just
help it along yeah what but
I'm speechless like I can't find what
part of it they're they're not sure
about like I can't find the root of this
community it's so beta bro to do listen
to this he's saying he has dogs or a
squeezer you squeeze it inside them I
bet like a dropper but I guess you
organic would be um bro imagine if
that's how you had to get a girl
pregnant like if you couldn't dance oh
Brad Brad you were a big Andrew Tate
Enthusiast though what are you talking
about but the thing is Brad is legit
he's not a bandwagoner he's been doing
this [ __ ] before Andrew Tate I mean
listen I'm not going to argue about that
no I'm saying you didn't just follow
like Andrew didn't change you you've
been doing this okay it was a big part
of the reason I think that he's
completely blasted is like
as this conversation goes on it's just
like incoherent he's just like kind of
jumping all over the place that or they
did a jump cut there where they cut out
something even more heinous bro no I
don't know but it's just how could there
be a jump cut there and they and they
didn't cut the I don't know man The Jerk
there might actually be no that seems
like okay let me go back it was just
like a hard like right let's turn in the
conversation let's look where the drink
stands and stuff like that yeah if
there's a jump cut here then we are
truly living in The Darkest Timeline
all right let's watch the drinks he's
been doing this [ __ ] before Andrew take
way back more Brad you were a big game
like a dropper but I guess you organic
would be um bro imagine if that's how
you had to get a girl pregnant like if
you couldn't dance oh Brad Brad you were
a big Andrew Tate Enthusiast though
the drinks are in the same place though
the hand on the mic changes the my the
hand is on the mic all of a sudden I
mean that's how they do it or uh uh bro
these are some freaky ass dogs or a
squeezer you squeeze it inside them I
bet like a dropper but I guess organic
would be um that's how you had to get a
girl pregnant like if you couldn't dance
oh Brad Brad you were a big inch yeah
there you go the hand was behind his
head and now it's on the mic so he said
something completely [ __ ] up yeah even
more so [ __ ] up that even these guys
had to cut it out so somebody watch this
back
gave it the consideration that the whole
shtick about him jerking off his dog is
fine but whatever happens here was too
far
what somebody watched that back and made
the conscious decision to leave it in
and they made the cut here I mean that I
can't believe what I'm
learning this is
cut them off
yeah if you what was the Super
interesting to me
I like this by the way
is if you go to the comments
this was why I was like nobody's talking
about it I'm like nobody's talking about
this man just said he jerks his dog
Bradley Martin is the best podcast host
on the platform how does how does that
work bro you just like like how does
that work how do dogs breed
all jokes aside Brad and Steve is the
friendship that we all strive for
Brad is the Big Brother Steve didn't
know about uh did you guys see the part
where Steve was talking about jerking
off his dog or did you all just gloss
over that
uh-oh Ila commented
she just said no
[Music]
sorry Ela I don't know how much you've
been watching but this man jerks off his
dog and he's and I mean go back and
watches
raw talk feels like the right place for
Steve to talk about what happened Steve
being Kim you're not talking about
jerking off the dog
find the rust of the Raw
Steve being cancer is literally dumb and
brother I know you'll continue to be a
good guy giving and finding success in
what you do next
no mention of the dog jerk off
it's nice to see that Steve's drug
dealer is supporting him in these hard
times
[Laughter]
Big Ups Brad Steve we can hear the
depression in your voice guys guys guys
guys
how is no
there's not one mention of the dog
in the top comments um I use the YouTube
search or whatever and just search for
the word dog
bro the dog story is an interesting turn
Steve jerking the dog off had me rolling
okay that's funny to Daniel here bro why
is Steve jerking off his dog yo if the
dog [ __ ] is real what the [ __ ] no shot
Steve jerks his dog what the [ __ ]
Steve just casually jerking off his dog
off what yeah so none of these are
floating up which I wonder if they're he
must be deleting them so everybody's
just going to ignore how he tricks off
his dog yeah I mean they're people are
noticing but for whatever reason I don't
know if it's deleting comments or
whatever definitely deleting comments
there's not one single comment on the
top that mentions yeah
and I'm going down now this is like one
like [ __ ] I mean no dog jerk off
mentioned oh I made it to the Philly
just thumbnail okay Philly geez let's go
okay so are you trying to get back to me
what does this neck action dude
dude Philly D's the man stop he subbed
to me I'm just saying he subbed me on
Twitter
absolute Legend he asked you Philly
number one in his transitions when he
goes from story to story he uses an
audio wasn't sure if that was real or it
is
oh so he's such a kiss as he's trying to
tear us apart
he's on your side he's on your side bro
he's like one of our only allies on the
internet and you've gotta critique him
it's a it's a joke come on guys also
he's having you do the L he's doing
you're doing the L that's like a sneak
diss too it's [ __ ] up I know he's
supporting me about the Cav cop show
actually you should preview it let's see
what he says okay I want to see if he
goes in against Cav or what I know I
went to Steve will do its uh Instagram
to see if he's talking about us at all
and I found out he has a discount code
for his full send uh protein powder
whatever it is and it's Bill Cosby
that's the discount I tried it it works
discount code is built Cosby yeah
whoa we'll send baby
are they selling sleep pills
it is because they are doing right yeah
wow
whoa okay wait here is the full send
pre-workout
code Bill Cosby for 50 off
pre-focus and energy one and with a free
drop of of uh dodges
for added protein
aren't they actually selling sleeping
aid though like um
code Bill Cosby
awesome
love that
going back to Philly D the first line of
this video is Ethan Klein's Ryan
Kavanaugh with his dick no shot he says
that
in the face with his dick yeah sure
we'll send the link don't hold out on me
in the face with his dick oh my God
wow
wow Philly by the way Philly's a real
one absolute Legend we joke we joke with
each other he's a great guy skinny
Legend it's very skinny about he doesn't
like being called a glowing Legend you
guys want to know I don't think he said
he doesn't like being called it I think
he said
it motivated him to lose weight well
it's kind of like
demeaning it doesn't help when he's
trying to lose weight to hear that
because you guys don't you're not like
real Philly defense like me
but that's what he said
right the guy the compliment I think
he's me I I understand where he's coming
from but skinny Legend is not it's not
really even about weight you know what I
mean yeah no I I don't think there's any
ill intent when people say it he's just
saying how he feels about it yeah
because it came off of electrician
calling him fat or something I get it
but I do think he's a skinny Legend if
you want if you want me to stop saying
that Philly let me know but you're you
are skinny you're so healthy now I'm so
happy for you
love the way you come metaphorically
speaking stop it get some help and he
did so with the help of Lady Justice if
you don't know Ethan has a massively
successful podcast oh love that baby
that's right talk to me talk to me baby
Philly okay I'm gonna like this [ __ ]
y'all let's go three podcasts and Ethan
has a relationship with lawsuits kind of
like how I have a relationship with
cookies I know it's best for me not to
even there's like some meaning going on
this is a new thing with the meme I
think he switched it up the style a
little bit recently I I have noticed
that in some of the recent Philly D
videos okay I like it I like experiments
a little creative experimenting with the
format I love everything he does I love
everything about him I'm gonna back it
up I love that you support my guys even
though it's causing a little bit of
friction because a B's Allegiance are in
question now no no no no no no he's
talking about he's always made Philly
first right okay
just as I said he's always been clear
just as I always suspected
like I honestly don't know if any other
Creator out there has had to deal with
more lawsuits than this guy but I don't
want to know he's not the one starting
the lawsuits and he just keeps winning
them but there's most recent ones yeah
dude
I love and let's not forget
when I first got sued Philly's the one
who really stepped up and helped me more
than anyone right big old doinks I
wasn't going to raise money but Philly
started the kindness of his heart
and it really helped us out so I mean
Philly will always be a real one for
them yeah when you stole it yeah and
then I pocketed it and bought
a mattress pocketed a third Mansion I
pocketed all the 150 000.
fought a lawsuit for two years
[Music]
on discount apparently uh-huh you know
what's the best part it can start
telling that live that my attorney told
me you can see in his public filing
because someone sued keemstar for
defamation yes
he won and recovered attorneys fees
right
and the returnings fees attorney's fees
he recovered it was about 150 000. right
so he knows he knows how much it costs
yes exactly
yeah
yeah
multiple ongoing cases with these two
for a while now with some already coming
down in Ethan's favor earlier this year
Ethan revealed one case involving a
website that he made mocking trailer
founder Ryan Kavanaugh had been thrown
out there was also a case that I want to
do a correction it's it's for public
knowledge it's not mocking him at all
where he was even of tortious
interference over remarks he made saying
the trailer falsely advertised Kevin
Hart as a trailer user but even then
filing an anti-slap motion which was
later granted with legal commentator
Emily D Baker explaining that this means
the cases Prejudice cannot be refiled
and Klein can go after trailer for all
legal fees and costs which they are
entitled to based on this rule which
brings us to the latest update in this
Saga because yesterday Ethan tweeted
just one 100 of our attorney fees from
trailer for their frivolous and
malicious lawsuit but adding I doubt I
will ever see a scent of that though
because they seem to be on the verge of
bankruptcy but notably this he didn't
read the last part uh we'll get to we'll
cover it our situation is not over as
Ethan himself noted our copyright and
defamation lawsuits are still ongoing we
will have updates in September hopefully
that copyright suit likely being in
reference to one regarding the alleged
distribution of a Jake Paul fight as
well as the alleged defamation one
likely being one coming from Ryan
Kavanaugh but also taking a closer look
at this this is not the end of the bad
stuff for trailer or what was Ethan
talking about with them possibly having
to declare bankruptcy what's the money
situation are there other problems and
parents bro this man is a missionary
Philly is a [ __ ] prophet of God y'all
better give respect to put respect on
his name
why everyone got to say it talk about me
like this I don't even like Ethan that
much but this is a huge dub that's like
everyone got to mention me like that on
the internet these days you notice that
anytime I come up it's always I don't
even like Ethan but
you know
here we go shout out Jackie's highlight
videos the way you covered H3 lawsuit
story from the beginning was amazing
thank you
I love how Ethan keeps running his
lawsuits me too girl
me too girly
but I like that this is the top comment
I don't even like Ethan that much but
that's a huge job what did I do what did
I do to deserve this scorn from the from
people
he said that much
he didn't say he hates me right but like
he feels like he has to qualify his
statement of support
this is what started my whole beef with
keemstar comment like this yeah maybe
you should beef with this random Youtube
five years watch your back don't let it
go for five [ __ ] years you should
tweet him death to all menaces
death to all local menaces
what can I do though like you know I I
want to be liked again everybody hates
me everyone used to love me like five
years six seven ten years ago
it's the Arc of the internet my friend
also you
attacked everyone ruthlessly all the
time
I have to do nobody likes me if you're a
fan of anyone on the internet other than
me you probably hate me that's a that's
a problem that's why I'm trying to I'm
trying to we burn a bridge every day
over here I know I know it's bad it's
bad
I Bradley I was supposed to be dogs I
was trying to make up with Bradley but
you're supposed to be dogs with him yeah
oh boy I wanted to be dogs with them and
then get jerked off oh no no no no
no well I'm winning these lawsuits for
all you guys if you hate me or not
have you ever seen an uglier mug in your
life damn what a monster
that is wow I think Philly whitened his
teeth too in the Photoshop oh oh he must
have yeah he touched him up I I pressed
the wrong button there yeah
you said have you ever seen an uglier
mug in your life and Ian switched to my
face by accident
no come on everyone knows
Abby's a handsome king he's he's
beautiful I still like Billy Moore he's
beautiful
I love you Philly what can I say
drive angry Phil actually invited me to
go hiking with him which was really nice
because he knows I was trying to lose
weight
yeah I know I should I should I I was
just like it's just hard for me to
commit to do anything
but he's such a sweetheart I should go
hike with him you should
Vlog it
yeah we love Philly dude
but that's so exciting
you guys thought I was joking but check
this out
I wasn't joking check a Discord yo code
Bill Cosby full sense sleep what is
business do these guys have selling
sleep aid
you guys don't even know how
reproduction works and using the code
Bill Cosby that well that's way too
[ __ ] far that's [ __ ] that is it's
like actually [ __ ] up
what's in this [ __ ] man
I sent the link below besides dog GHB
well it's a certain type of scooping
method that goes into the supplements
dude supplements golly man these guys
this is how you make a lot of money in
the manosphere right when grifting you
sell your own
you sell your own supplements
who's buying from Full send there's like
reputable companies with chemists
and scientists why would you go to
Infowars or full send for your [ __ ]
supplement needs
you know they're just if they're doing
anything it's just repackaging the same
[ __ ] that you would buy
uh
let's see they're selling stamina
liver reset
so they're marketing to the alcoholics
yeah and if you'd have uh fake steroids
is good as well I believe what steroids
if you take steroids I think it's good
to have like liver pills with it at the
same time oh okay okay sleep NAD what
the [ __ ] is NAD booster
well when you take a lot of steroids
they tend to shrink and so you might
need some sort of supplement to
encounter let me see what's in this
these statements have not been evaluated
by the Food and Drug Administration
this product is not Senate to diagnose
treat or cure or prevent any diseases
really every supplement has that even
ones that are like quote unquote more
reputable
no it just really surprises me just read
that on theirs though
it was uh distributed by full send
Fitness
what is in this [ __ ] thing that makes
you sleepy magnesium
gamma
theotine
rufilin Hydra
is this oh melatonin she just you could
have just said melatonin
you don't have to put all this other
[ __ ] in it to make it seem like it's
doing something
it's just melatonin it's not that
serious
oh my God why
bundle and Save
they should sell jerk off Dog gloves
perfect soft
because most latex gloves are kind of
rubbery and sticky I think Steve will do
is just to do branded
nice and soft dog jerk off gloves
yeah the markup is insane I mean how
much can you buy
melatonin pills on Amazon for it's like
these guys are selling it for 35 bucks
uh again for eight bucks seven bucks for
a pack of like a 90 of them how many
pills are in this
30. oh my God a dollar a pill 90 counts
or 689 on Amazon yeah and that's the
same thing that's the same thing
I can't help you if you're this dumb
nobody can
hi Ethan could you please wish my wife
Shelby a happy birthday she turns 25
this Saturday and off the rails
unfortunately uh Shelby you are no
longer eligible to be
uh date in Leonardo so Connor nothing to
worry about there that is so sad yeah uh
Happy Birthday uh Shelby sorry about
getting too [ __ ] old
25 yikes
lubed gloves with finger condoms oh my
God they're selling that
no but that he should yeah that's what
he needs I actually I want to keep
watching this I don't know if I'm
belaboring it but I just find this
endlessly fascinating
true Tate enthusiasts though what are
you talking about but the thing is Brad
is legit he's not a bandwagoner he's
been doing this [ __ ] before Andrew Tate
I mean listen I'm not going to argue
about that no I'm saying you you're just
like Andrew didn't change you you've
been doing this it's true okay you want
my if I have a there's such an
incoherent cut but Their audience is so
dumb they don't even notice like this
conversation makes no sense from now
literally none what are you not
following he says you've been doing this
[ __ ] yeah they what [ __ ] the [ __ ] Ethan
Bradley Martin has been doing this [ __ ]
yeah okay
Ash cam are you here
or do you go to the bathroom
Ash said I know this is old but cam is
my celebrity crush he's so handsome
never know
we'll tell him when he comes back
he'll find out he says you're hot
all right thank you Dan she's like he's
gonna get super stressed [ __ ] he just
scratched off a log because he's yeah
he's gonna trip over that shoddy potty
whatever that was called stool kid you
wanted to be a daughter if I want to
hear these two reasons
first off story Brad get when he gets
angry he gets angry and he may kill you
so I'm gonna say that
okay what does that have to do with the
rest of the story one reason is or the
first reason that relates to that is
that I want her I just hope she's a
friend us this this uh wonderful uh gal
Ash donated and said that you're her
celebrity crush
and that you're very handsome she said
not me you got the wrong guy thank you
though no but she's definitely talking
about you
thank you very much
what's up dude
and deals with a bunch of guys you hope
my daughter that I that and I hope that
she let me go back or the first reason
that relates to that is that I want her
I just hope she's a [ __ ] a [ __ ] and
Deals a bunch of guys huh you hold my
daughter future daughter he wants his
daughter to be a [ __ ]
and I hope that she only likes black
guys what what the [ __ ] is this
conversation
all right let's Let It Roll you once
they're a [ __ ] and that she only likes
black guys ladies and gentlemen you
heard it here
code Bill Cosby dude and stobe and I
hope you have and I just want you to
deal with that as a dad who has anger
issues and he's a [ __ ] jacked guy
like you I just want you to deal with
that and then two I want to [ __ ] her
myself wow honestly thinking about her
hypothetical daughter he's saying I
would wish a [ __ ] woman who just has
sex with black guys on you
to test your patients uh-huh and he's
confused why YouTube doesn't want him
I'm do you have anything to do with that
frankly Olivia it's just gambling I
don't even think that it doesn't even
have anything to do with like the
content that I don't think so actually I
think it's all gambling
if I had to guess well everything he's
[ __ ] said so far seems red flag red
flag red flag
I can't stop watching this dude you have
a kid and she's 18. I swear to God if
I'm still listening I'll be like Selena
I have to [ __ ] Bradley's daughter I just
need to have that on him and just be
like whenever anything's going on or
does she have a choice or no just to
check just remind everyone this is a
seamless stream of Consciousness from I
jerk my dog off to a hypothetical two
you're just like Andrew Tate to I hope
you have a daughter that I can [ __ ] when
she's an adult Steve will yank it you
withheld you withheld a key detailer Dan
what'd I miss that she hope he hopes she
just [ __ ] black guys
that does seem like a contradiction
though
he's not black I don't think he plans on
giving her a choice is what I'm picking
up he says I'm gonna take her
whether she wants to or not
is what I'm getting
from my man here
imagine being just being able to say yo
I [ __ ] your daughter
I want that on you so bad like I would
same with your mom I would [ __ ] your mom
what bro my he's he's on something I'm
I'm guessing mom always [ __ ] your mom
what the [ __ ] are you saying I would
love to have that [ __ ] on you you would
[ __ ] my mom like I wanted that's crazier
than the dog I want to just be at the
gym and now you're like [ __ ] hitting
bench press I'm trying to be like yo
like I [ __ ] your mom wow that's so
[ __ ] twisted yeah but that that's not
more twist than the dog butt okay
so we were wondering I I'm done with
this uh wow if you want I mean I
recommend watching it the whole thing is
a pretty wild ride
pretty good I mean pretty entertaining
I'm not gonna lie
kind of hard
welcome back to another episode yeah so
we were wondering is this a is this
illegal to jerk your dog off like that
or
I mean it seems like bestiality
I mean if you're not doing it
intentionally to like artificially
inseminate an animal
it seems borderline but where's the
legal you need to be like do you need us
a certificate to jerk off a dog do you
need to be a like your occupation need
to be a breed like where do we say a
normal guy can jerk off a dog I know I
think he misunderstands the term
bestiality I think he's a beast you know
and he just hears beasts and he's like
oh beastiality I'm a beast yeah dude I'm
a beast brought up
can we get some fact checking like can
you just Google is it illegal to jerk
off my dog yeah
as long as you back me up if anyone ever
takes money yeah
because clearly some people are allowed
to jerk off dogs right because there's
breeders what would be the legal term
for jerking off it says fellatio no no
no no pleasuring pleasuring no also not
that milking that's definitely not that
masturbating oh the first the first
result is a bestiality if you masturbate
while you get why your pet humps yes
I believe it's not
it's not who's according to who
oh somebody said Yahoo questions Steve
needs a professional raw doctor you
should have Gideon
yeah is we can't we need some
we need a legal expert is there is there
people that specialize in
uh dogs the term is extraction oh
extraction good
is it illegal to extract my own dog
I did not put my dick anywhere near my
dog I think the line that makes it
illegal is when you're throwing a
children's cartoon yeah that crosses the
line of legality in my eyes yeah and
well too yeah and everything
to get back to this person you're it so
this person masturbates while their dog
humps them
it seems that way yeah
is it a guy or a girl
I didn't say but the top response is
yeah it's doophilia don't feel bad
there's plenty of us out here
okay all right that's enough internet no
bucket required j-r-h-n-br
-h-n-br just the right height is
required
you could probably get like a sheep veg
Fleshlight if you're into that
saying this remedies out there maybe a
cow veg Fleshlight
you think they'd be different cow and
sheep yeah I mean a cow is bigger I
guess that's true I mean they make horse
[ __ ] dildos that's what I'm saying yeah
so
this is nasty this is Jesus Christ keep
going keep going baby let's not stop
We're In Too Deep now it's really bad
really that bad go ahead what does this
have to do with the league did you just
find out I'm not finally Galaxy I said
I'm pretty sure this episode's already
monetized so we might as well why uh an
hour-long conversation about beastiality
what it could be
what are you talking about Dan go ahead
baby we'll find out I guess it's not
about the legality it's just gnarly it's
just follow-up questions under this post
yeah all right go ahead We're In Too
Deep oh boy what will happen if dog
sperm goes into a human female job
all right enough let's move on
immediately
but it's definitely illegal though right
like if you're pleasuring your dog
that [ __ ] ain't good
yeah that got to be illegal if if
bestiality is illegal no I think so no I
mean the line but then I'm wondering
where's the line the line the line is
very obvious are you doing it yeah are
you a professional breeder who is doing
this too who's to say three dogs who's
to say Steve's not a professional
breeder I I am I'm gonna go ahead if
you're a prosecutor how are you going to
prove that he doesn't have the correct
well to jerk off his dog it is well for
one you would probably ask for those
credentials and two it's on video him
explaining exactly how and why he's
doing he's saying it's not that black
and white uh it's very black and white
he says his reasoning is because his dog
deserves the best the pillow isn't
cutting it I'll tell you what the man
loves the dog and I love my dogs too so
you want to give them the best I do wish
the best for them right to think about
the best
I'll do you know what I'm jerking
shutter off when I get home stop I'm
doing it man you know I'd love that dog
too much not to treat him do you want to
take treating him tonight
I'm gonna get both my dogs on both sides
come on
[Music]
some gloves cheddar Alfredo come on now
boy yeah throw me those
Steve will do it Tommy oh they're here
right now come on
I love you too much nothing
I love you too much
Shredder or afraid of got up he knew
something he's like damn
now oh go ahead love
yeah
now they can like see I was making a
joke and Ethan was making a joke there's
no difference yeah they can use that
yeah of course not go ahead now we gave
them an out I'm giving you an out man
take it listen I don't want you to have
to face this down take that out there
you go we're all kidding we're all
kidding
but in the meantime get stop doing that
I think we all hope it's a joke yeah
even if it's a horrible all right all
right Shredder Alfredo have a seat boys
I cannot wait to see the clickbait about
the videos the videos on this episode
put on uh hey Ethan Klein did what
put on uh
this is a shack delete me delete me yeah
yeah which was do you know what's funny
about that that was with the milk boys
that's true oh right it all comes back
together it's all full circle all right
boys full sentence I'm putting on your
favorite I'm putting on a Pinocchio now
let's now you boys get lion and Let Me
Whip jerk off them peckers
I'm about to bait your dicks look like
Pinocchio been lying all day now
this music is Pinocchio
I love these dogs too damn much
right
all right just me okay
nobody's enjoying this bit
sorry
just me huh all right
I love them too much Dan
what can I say they mean the mirror they
mean the world to me do not come
holy [ __ ] they they mean too much we
really are off the rails it is off the
rails and we didn't even get to the
trailer part
okay maybe we should yeah let's
transition
um wait let's transition like they did
so and anyway
um I hope that your daughter gets only
gets uh
I was about to do a Mel Gibson
remember what Mel Gibson said carefully
I do remember some of the things Mel
Gibson said please don't repeat those
things
is that the voice messages please
I love the fact that Ryan's lawyers are
probably gonna watch this episode
[Laughter]
all right guys
also uh to Ryan's attorneys you're
probably never going to get paid
okay
here okay good to me telling you to [ __ ]
yourself demons first hand this one's
for Ryan's attorneys who will be
watching this everybody please
hey Ryan's attorneys is what we think of
your client and you guys okay
also you're suckers you're never gonna
get paid okay thank you right [ __ ] you
and your dumb ass company Bro
[ __ ] You [ __ ] you all right [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you and your dog and [ __ ] you if
you don't like it I gotta pee again I
don't know what's going on but I'm gonna
run and then we'll get into the trailer
thing but okay don't go away because
this this is good okay don't leave any
good stuff it must be the PSL hey wait
why are you taking alfredo with you I'm
kid I'm kidding bro put the gloves back
give us the gloves back
quick PSL update uh ELO didn't like her
pumpkin spice either so I've been
sipping shout out Eli has taste is the
thing
oh classy lady very sugary I kind of
hate it now anyone here from Arizona
oh they have this if anyone hears from
Sweden guys go to McDonald's go buy a
Cookie Monster freak Shake they're very
good thank you guys you sponsored yeah
no it's just very good I want want the
fupa troopas to enjoy I'm jealous I saw
that it looked incredible you guys very
good anyone here from Arizona send one
in the mail
I went in the mail
[Music]
go off King
nothing I was just waiting to uh oh [ __ ]
I just clicked off it where'd it go
somebody is sitting in the ER right now
watching the show and I wanted to wish
them
good luck on their surgery they said
good luck I'm so sorry you're wearing
headphones I clicked off of it for a
second yeah I hope you have had funds
too I clicked off of it for one sec here
it is sitting in the ER for appendicitis
and I'm grateful that my history family
to keep me company peace and love I hope
it goes smoothly you got that appended
out yo [ __ ] those
you don't even need it rip that [ __ ] out
right right down there in the after with
the tonsils right with
um what else I mean
gallbladder my big tongue and the
gallbladder out is that one that one can
go too my big toe get rid of that but uh
Kev Longo
remember for nine months I wish you well
I hope it goes smoothly yes and I hope
you're wearing headphones I would suck
if someone next to you was hearing us
say uh can you legally
jerk off your dog yeah glad you're at
the ER and not the veterinarian for this
episode
somebody used their member message to
say I am throast you know I don't know
if that's true
but if it is
thank you for your service
well thank you for everything you do
well
well not uh maybe what I said in the
chat earlier uh he posted one about that
huh
Jimmy
[Music]
yeah he made a meme saying that he is
thrust well I guess he didn't make it
gotcha Gigi thank for the 50 donation
too oh GG he's on the 50. thank you for
the donors actually before we get into
the trailer thing there's one thing I
want to show sure real fast
is that Jimmy Lee's social media has
been so crazy
he he just probably posted he posted one
that is probably the one that went too
far and uh may even get his accounts
just now yeah here hold on send it to me
let me see personally personally it's my
favorite
let me just say that what the [ __ ] is
this
a b Starkiller the inter-dimensional
sorcerer audio audio audio look at the
look at the capture look at the cap
right
kill Star Killer
whoops
well it's just a Star Wars character
it's just an old time
it's an old-timey joke death threads
dude he does somebody is sending him
these and he's not even thinking about
it and I mean I don't think Jimmy has
any idea what's happening I'm getting
blamed for all of them for some reason
no it's not cam click the Jersey Outlaw
and go to the one from yesterday that
this was the craziest one he's posted
maybe like 20 since yesterday
I'm not even exaggerating there's been
like a million new dude he he called me
at 5 30 this morning what's going on on
the screen can you switch off of that
thank you
uh
yeah what did he say I didn't answer 5
30 in the morning you don't answer Jimmy
when he calls you okay 5 30 in the
morning not that one go down
down down
Jesus Christ he's supposed to lie what
the [ __ ] Jimmy
do you have any idea what is happening
here this is insane
so that one on the left left get that
one
this one was a hit look at this [ __ ]
okay let's Analyze This
I went too far in the metaverse
somebody get me out of here
Jimmy Lee's in Minecraft on the TV
wait look sorry I was trying to
Bobby Lee is giving Trish an ultrasound
and Zach's dad is on the
is on the monitor the ultrasound he's
the baby he's baby get your Jimmy worm
this shit's crazy is this is kind of
creative what's happening here I mean I
I I can't knock they are good [ __ ] posts
but they're not mine but we found out
for a fact that he might not be making
these but he is posting them oh he's
posting them he's definitely found that
out yeah
also we learned that Mason may not be
real yeah I was about to say I
personally I am fairly convinced I don't
want to sell anybody out but several
people that have been
working on these beams for Jimmy and
kind of working in proximity to Jimmy
have reached out to me and I inquired
about Mason I was like what do you know
about this Mason character uh can we get
in touch with them somehow we want to
talk to them and none of them
have ever spoken to Mason or know
anything about it Mason doesn't exist I
think it's another Alter Ego I think
it's Rossi baby I'm a fake his fake
manager Steve Rossi it's another of the
mindset that Mason was real at first but
he's just he has such a big team now
that he's expanded and doesn't work for
Mason anymore
yeah so anyway I wanted to share that
with you guys but we can move on now we
don't have to get too lost in the sauce
there but Jimmy leaves on an interesting
Journey there on Instagram
for sure
all right so let's get to the the
good stuff here
so I got a call from my lawyers
yesterday
with the great news that
not only did we win our petition to get
our attorney's fees back for the
tortures interference but we got a
hundred percent of the attorney's
feedback
and I want to tell you guys
[Music]
that getting 100 back is not normal
usually get like 50 to 80 back a hundred
percent is the judge being like you guys
are [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
we're not [ __ ] with trailer here's
what I said yeah my man I said I just
won 100 of our attorneys fees from
triller for their frivolous and
malicious lawsuit I doubt I'll ever see
a scent of that though and I really
don't
because they seem to be on the verge of
bankruptcy HR social media guy DME if
you're looking for a new job and I
thought that was considerate
I actually would I I even followed
triller so that if he wants to DM me he
can nice
I thought that was big of you thank you
I thought it was nice I'm being serious
uh Reach Out
nobody folks we're Thriller
actually to celebrate I want to announce
a competition okay
we will pick a first second and third
place winner who's getting cash prizes I
want a Ryan Kavanaugh diss track
from all the fine fupa troopers at home
who want to participate
will listen we'll give you all the
exposure we will celebrate you first
place gets 500 bucks second place gets
300 bucks
their place gets a hundred bucks submit
your freestyles diss tracks to podcasts
at h3h3productions.com
I would love to see what you guys have
to make uh we should set a deadline too
when do you want to present these or
like pick the winners and we could do it
next week like a week we could do it on
Wednesday next week so Wednesday next
week we'll announce
our favorite three yeah so this this is
this is great I really want to hear from
you guys we've seen a tremendous work
from you guys in the past when we've had
these kind of competitions
uh yeah uh good point cam make sure it's
a copyright free beat uh or a radio or
something or or original
um but we will we'll test upload them
beforehand and see if it gets claimed
and you will be disqualified if you use
some sort of copyright music thank you
Dad yeah so please mind you please be
careful of that because we don't want to
disqualify you but uh obviously we won't
have a choice
and um so that that I'm looking forward
to also I'm happy to announce that
November where I finally decided on a
recipient for chair a charity Habitat
for Humanity as you guys know Ryan Kevin
a stiffed Habitat for Humanity he
pledged a million dollars had a whole
celebration a whole ceremony on video
and he ended up not donating any money
which is incredible I want to make that
up to them
it's not fair that they got schemed and
scammed by Ryan Cavanaugh
so just to correct you he ended up
donating 35 000 35 000 yeah how much did
he promise a million three million
dollars
that's three percent of the three and a
half percent of the promised
if you want to read more about that you
can go to the strong Kavanaugh looks
like Harvey weinstein.com Google it yeah
Google yeah Google it sure and then
scroll down click the page yeah yeah so
uh we'll be doing uh Habitat for
Humanity in honor of him and in November
and that'll be fantastic uh moving on
here I have
the emotions that were granted yesterday
and there's some really interesting
stuff in here for example
he shall pay us within 10 business days
this guy has 10 business states
whoa or
it starts accruing interest at 10 a year
that's awesome this dude has
10 days to pay me he's not going to pay
me a dime I guarantee it we're gonna
have to send it to collections which is
great in itself but the amount of people
that triller owes money to at this point
from everything we're reading is uh
exceptional it's incredible
how is it that he's I wasn't this man
Ryan Cavanaugh convinced so many people
to give him money again he's lost all
your money again he's made fools of all
of you
yeah
so he owes us 61 thousand dollars
which this one was actually really cheap
um this one was really easy to beat
it was just a uh anti-slap this is the
most absurd of of all the lawsuits
probably was this the one for the bad
reviews oh yeah
so that one was like super dumb easy we
just filed one brief so 60 000 is we got
off pretty pretty cheap on this one
so um that's just one of four actions
though so obviously I'm gonna be in the
whole lot of money by the end of this
but yeah I don't think I'm gonna die but
you got 10 days baby the clock is
ticking I mean we should have a timer I
mean this was from yesterday this was
ordered this morning this morning yeah
okay so what's his deadline
well 10 days from this today would be
the 10th right of September oh did you
include the new one because this one was
stamped by the judge but it's the same
version
uh these sent you this morning these are
the ones that you sent this morning oh
it was yeah I don't see the stamp but
anyway this is the one that was approved
it's the same thing no changes
so when does Ryan Kavanagh OS 60 000 I'm
not sure is it like a midnight it would
either be like at midnight well 10
business days so you don't count the
week oh business days
one two three four five six seven
eight nine nine ten it would be the 14th
which is exactly
not next Wednesday but the following
Wednesday so let's mark that from now
we're going to do a countdown here
triller Ryan Cavanaugh I know you're
watching this is we're putting you on
notice man you owe me 61 000 bucks let's
get
come on let's get paying buddy
you guys like that
you guys like that
so ordered
trailer shall pay defendant the amount
of 61 000 within 10 business days of
this order
the award of 61 000 shall accrue the
maximum statuary interest rate upon
entry of this order it is so ordered
[ __ ]
you guys like that [ __ ]
should I donate the 60k to Habitat for
Humanity if I ever get it which I won't
right I would do that
if I don't want to say it out loud in
case you already had earmarked that for
something no I would 100 seems like a
great [ __ ] you to get money from Ryan
Kavanaugh and give it to the Charities
yeah he's stiff yo that's not his real
teeth color
I think that's real
I what who's to say what is he really
[ __ ] yeah he just he eats cigarette
butts
like he just loves diving into ashtrays
and just [ __ ] slamming cigarette
butts
I love that he loves the accolades he's
attending a party at his honor
but he doesn't love so much the giving
he loves the celebrating
doesn't love the giving part
yeah if they pay me back all 100 oh
donate to Habitat people are uh pointing
out that uh Labor Day is next week so I
guess it would that wouldn't count as a
business day so one day later Thursday
so on Friday we can do it sure that
Friday would be a good day
yeah I mean hopefully if they pay me
back we can get a big old check
have a whole have maybe we can invite I
don't know if we could get someone from
habitat from Humanity to come celebrate
me yeah we can get a girl with a helmet
we can hold a big and I'll even donate
it to them before they come celebrate me
so they know there's no funny business
so that'd be great
I mean they're great people I wouldn't
stiff them loves asking well I I it's
technically the 15th but the 16th is uh
the after dark that we would likely talk
about it because we probably wouldn't
talk about it on Leftovers on Thursday
uh love you should add the countdown on
on our on the does Ryan Kavanaugh look
like Harvey Weinstein so we can go check
up on that yeah technically the due date
is the is the 15th so if you want to do
a countdown I guess have it go to the
15th
yeah I'll be gracious I'll give him I'll
give him the extra grace period one
greatest Edge on the
all the air on the edge of giving him
more time
but this toy podcast as he referred to
us here I'll keep going leave this this
uh
who says I'm vindictive
that was in my astrological sign I don't
believe that you're not a Virgo yeah I'm
not a Virgo anyway
um so it is so ordered
you hear that
[ __ ] face
how's this taste [ __ ]
stupid ass idiot [ __ ] loser
and also shout out to all the [ __ ]
idiots on the internet he said I was
going to jail yep people were straight
up Ethan could go to jail for this yeah
well he's paying me 61 000.
with interest
it is so ordered [ __ ]
suck it
that's what's up dude a billionaire
tried to [ __ ] with us
let's revisit this DM he sent former
billionaire yeah I should mean yeah he's
still got money he's still rich though
the funny thing about this [ __ ] with
triller is like the only one who's
really making money at the end of the
day who's able to like put it under a
mattress or whatever proverbially
is Ryan Kavanaugh
again we learned he lost almost a
billion dollars last year of investors
money but you know he lives in like a
sick ass house in the Hills
um
this is what I
tweeted yesterday let's remember those
messages that Ryan Kavanaugh sent us
this guy tried to Big Time me he's a
billionaire as she likes to present
himself he was one at one point valued
at a billion
he really came up to us and thought he
could bully us he said Ethan I'm not
sure why you have decided to take it
upon yourself to malign attack and
slander and defame me I didn't do that
[Music]
I mean I said you're ugly does that
count
I said your life gets real it gets
railed by Brad the bull is that an
attack
I don't think so necessarily
I mean I mentioned that you have
multiple DUIs or wet and recklesses
whatever you call them I mean that's
that's not an attack that's just a
matter of fact isn't it
I do not know you I also don't know why
you are spending thousands of dollars to
have those dumb thousands of dummy
accounts post fake statements about me
on my Instagram and tens of thousands
to have fake app store reviews of
Chiller now hold the [ __ ] phone
that
is just not true
those are real people
who really don't like you or trailer
[Music]
you know and if you use trailer and you
don't like the experience it's well
within your right to give it a one star
I did
or five star if you like it right
anything in between right I encourage
you to actually use triller app in fact
I'm the only person in the world
encouraging people to download trailer
at this moment yep so in reality he
should be thanking me
and paying me which he is 61 000.
for my attorney fees right thank you
plus interest
thank you
yes so yeah leave a honest review is
what I was getting to worse yet you
dedicate an entire show of yours reading
your own fake reviews come on now that's
slander
while amusing
appreciate that and slightly annoying at
best I'm not even bothered
clearly by this [ __ ]
essay that he wrote you yeah he doesn't
care that he sent to you and to the
podcast
right which I didn't even notice till
months later I found it yeah I found it
like at 4am taking a [ __ ] and I was just
going through the DMS oh that's crazy
that he that much months later yeah that
must eat him up that we never even
looked at it
he says while amusing is slightly
annoying at best I would advise you to
stop and mitigate your damage now your
toy podcast I like that phrase toy do
you mean it
I mean clearly he doesn't take me
seriously or what we do here the toy
podcast
what did he mean by that
number 12 most listened to podcasts in
the world
I mean it is fun is that what you mean
by toy I agree I guess it's fun
toys yeah we have lots of food toys yeah
there you go
well this actually this has some utility
it's not just at home
I got some bunnies
those are toys
your toy podcast seems fun and all but
this is real business with real
consequence and you're causing real
damage I thought you didn't care
this is big boy business
clearly you are very unhappy and
Disturbed human to take it upon yourself
to attack someone you don't know with
false misleading information especially
at 10 10 spend tens of thousands of
dollars on it but it must stop tens of
thousands of dollars of his money just
to be clear
well he think no he his master at the
time he thought that you was that we
were hiring hordes of
um people who comment but which I always
thought was an interesting self-report
because he knows so much about buying
comments and traffic and stuff like I
don't know how much that stuff costs
anything about it
you have been warned
and I will not be threatened and
maligned and stand by idly okay [ __ ]
this dude thinks he has like a standing
army
not I'm just a dude man I'm not like a
[ __ ] hostile
foreign Nation govern yourself
accordingly
so I said I just took this moment to
appreciate just you know don't get
bullied Man by anyone
you know now that we've been awarded
attorney's fees I'd like to look back at
this DM I got from Ryan Kavanaugh
majority owner of triller threatening
and trying to Big Time me this is an
important reminder to never given to
bullies even if they are billionaires
[ __ ] Ryan Cavanaugh
when this is all over you should tweet
at him govern these nuts
all right that'll be the big uh you know
it's all leading up to that great moment
what is Ryan up to anyway
oh he's not really active oh he's
tweeting [ __ ] shitty articles about tick
tock
nice try idiot
it's too late for you now
he's still following me by the way
damn
I really wish he took the bait
and tried to call you out on thrusting
yeah
so that's kind of cab for you
um there's other things going on here
that I want to read
oh the timer's up already here so here
let me let me yeah oh that's so cool uh
I'm gonna type Ryan Kavanaugh in the
browser
you might want to hurry up oh
if the football Troopers crashed the
website here
here it is okay nice trailer's deadline
to pay
60
963 to Ethan Klein for attorney's fees
dude that's [ __ ] awesome
we're gonna have to check back on this
website yeah that's great yeah so
forgive me if I I missed this I was in
the restroom what happens if they don't
pay by that time
they start getting charged interest they
get charged interest okay I'm just
another idiot they owe money too yeah
get in line there's a long [ __ ] line
of people they owe money to yeah
you know what I mean it's so interesting
like you said that Ryan Kavanaugh
uh seems to know so much about how much
Bots cost
because when I I've noticed this before
but when I go to any random I just
picked one of his posts at random here
and then I clicked on the likes and
start clicking on some of these accounts
here
um
interesting that he has so many fans
uh with private serial posts oh my God
yeah oh that y'all
go back
this dude is Ryan's biggest fan go down
boy shout the [ __ ] out this guy's
following Ryan's career super close yeah
very interested this buyer is fantastic
he's very real seeming people uh this
one
okay private account
it's just interesting here's another big
fan of Ryan's right here yeah yeah these
all seem like real people for sure
[Music]
here's another one
um there was that one
and then there's another one I wanted to
read something good
uh what does this one say
yada yada yada
trailer I guess maybe they're
maybe that's it
yeah
but if he doesn't pay us the best
outcome is that
we just sent it to collections and then
they get they follow him forever
hopefully
um
there it is
also just since we're on the topic of
Chiller by the way people are asking we
still have two lawsuits left we've won
two of four halfway there baby
we won the website one he tried to take
down does rank have a look like Harvey
Weinstein he failed he tried to sue me
for tortious interference which is like
he blamed me for them getting one star
reviews which is outrageous
he said I was trying to interfere with
them doing business
even if I did which I'm not admitting to
I have nothing to do with those I only
encourage people to leave honest reviews
it's free it's free speech dumb dumb
so that's what I got the 61 000 for and
then we have upcoming the defamation one
Ryan is suing me personally for
defamation which is going to be
interesting because if he loses that one
then when we pursue legal fees he's
going to owe me personally and trailer
going bankrupt is not going to help him
absolve that debt my bad
and of course the copyright infringement
one which was the first one of all this
so I we're expecting to have some
updates in September
it's exciting
yeah so moving on I was when this came
out I started
is this the one I was getting to yeah
I was starting to look at their social
media and stuff
and I saw the twirler's official Twitter
account
posted this
okay now correct me if I'm wrong
but does this seem kind of [ __ ] up
they posted a meme of an orangutan
driving a
golf cart but golf car but do you notice
anything weird about this
is anything a little bit off about this
they're kind of conceding the point a
little bit here
I mean if you're if you're trying to
disrupt the market and
compete with Tick Tock it just seems a
little odd to me to post videos with the
tick tock timestamp on it
Tick Tock is our home I don't know I
don't know what to think about this has
the tick tocks timestamp and the trailer
time stamp
or Watermark I mean I just I find that a
little funny don't you guys
it's uh not the best look for the
official account to be promoting their
primary arrival
right he's like yo check out this Banger
video on tick tock
[Laughter]
so dumb maybe you shouldn't have offered
their social media guy job because that
was very gracious of you but this isn't
necessarily the best choice there's a
good chance that Ryan is the social
media guy he's like the only one left at
this company yeah exactly it's a
skeleton crew over there
uh but good the good news is for Ryan
you know he used to be a big movie
producer before he bankrupted his
company
but the good news is that he's back on
top he's making a new movie so hopefully
paying our legal fee shouldn't be an
issue
uh everyone's very excited for his new
movie
skill house
starring Bryce Hall
50 Cent
and uh who else someone else
a bunch of Zoomer influencers I've never
heard of before but I'm sure have like
50 million followers
do you know any of them Olivia did you
watch this
I did not you don't know the skill I
have their IMDb uh for the movie in the
dock with the list of the cast and
everything if you wanna
also can you post something that's under
there there's pretty funny comments yeah
he posted this to his Instagram page so
this is a big play for him he's back in
the movie making business and just like
before he knows how to pick him
worked well for him in the last uh time
he's got a formula he's got a formula
get things going
[Music]
I don't know
we're all connected I mean we're all
influencers we all have millions of
followers
yeah sorry I have tens of Millions
I don't think these are foreign
clapping and then one of saying this
n-word 50 the new jigsaw I'm here
there's only two comments that's so
great
Mason's managing his uh social media how
many likes though
all of his posts have right around 35
000 likes on the dot that's unusual what
are the Aussie of 30 000 views and two
comments that doesn't make any sense
that's that seems organic anyway let's
watch this is a big moment for him let's
not take this away from him rules if
your phone is not near you at all times
at the end of each round if you have the
fewest amount of views you know who I am
you died wait it's 50 that villain yeah
I'm not feeling jigsaw I'm not feeling
that man
not at all
yeah
it will only be one way
[Music]
and the rest
yeah yeah
um what do you guys think
l
I just L what's crazy
is let me look at the imv who's
producing this is he using triller money
to make this
I think so I remember we did actually
talk about this when they like announced
it in passing once when we were in our
era of talking about Ryan Kavanaugh
every single episode
um but I think it was just in the the
early stages of being talked about at
the time
yeah I'm just wondering who financed
this because
they're not getting their money back in
fact I think that this all plays into
his trailer bankruptcy plan
where who's financing this shouldn't it
say the production company or something
here
let's see
uh produced by
is there a way to find out who's
bankrolling this [ __ ]
uh yeah
um
probably the easiest way is to just look
it up on a very well regarded
respectable publication called variety
who's actually done quite a bit of
reporting on Ryan Cavanaugh over the
years right there's one in particular
about a skill house
as foreign movie
is so gory that the cameraman fainted
look at this
sure no way the cameraman fainted did
not happen
uh let me see what other stuff they've
written about it
yeah so everyone just gets
Proxima media okay so that's Ryan's
that's yeah
50 Cent boards [ __ ] pick skill house
will produce alongside Proxima medium
yeah this is Ryan's company yeah
Proxima media this website is horrible
I just don't get it man where did you
get the money for this
how is he making movies again it just
makes no sense
we've heard well over the years that
we've this has been going on now that
that's like his main skill is fleecing
investors out of money but I think he's
really good at that but at what point do
people keep giving them money I just
don't understand who wants me just
Google his name for Christ's sake read
his Wikipedia page well now don't talk
about making probably having a much
harder time now I hope so because of
that SEO that we've done but we didn't
do any SEO well I just mean the website
like being the top result when you look
for them because it's you know provides
relevant information yeah yeah which is
what Google values when you're ranking
yeah it's all up to Google it's not in
our hands or anything like that so right
it's just Google we didn't actually do
any SEO we literally just built the site
and and told people about it right which
is like the great the best way to build
your ranking just organically and by the
way to make it very clear like Google
has like spam like they removed spam
websites and like malicious websites so
it's very clear that our website is
there because it's supposed to be there
for educational purposes just want to
put that out there Mike S left a great
comment just another thing Bryce Hall
isn't going to get paid for oh no
Bryce knows how to pick them all right
Jazzy says Shane Dawson's Smiley movie
looked better
love that yeah it looks like a class
project to be honest
like a final dissertation yeah
like High School
um so there's that to look forward to
Ryan is uh gonna hit a big with that I'm
sure
and then it gets even juicier since
we're tap dancing on the poor sad Ryan
Kavanaugh's grave the same day that that
verdict came out that he owes our legal
fees Sony Music ladies and gentlemen
that's a big company right probably the
biggest is that the one you're found
your mom works for no
Sony Music I've heard of them
probably not a good company to cross
laughs
Sony music is suing triller alleging
copyright infringement and breach of
contract
I wonder if he thinks Sony music is a
toy company
he sent the C the the CEO of Sony music
I don't know what you're getting at but
your toy
music company is messing with real stuff
um
we can listen to it
Sony Music Sue's trailer alleging
copyright infringement and breach of
contract updated let's go guys who's up
for this finally Sony Music
Entertainment filed a lawsuit against
triller seeking millions of dollars in
Damages after the video sharing app
allegedly stopped paying licensing fees
in March 2022
according to the suit filed Monday in
New York federal court triller continued
to allow Sony music songs to be shared
on the app even after the Music Company
yeah I'll just read you the bullet
points oh there's an update uh Sony
Music Entertainment fought a lawsuit
seeking millions of dollars in Damages
according to the soup how's that an
updates the whole thing
yeah so apparently in March of last year
it was a long time
trailer stopped paying Sony music
foreign
they're like no which to me says
financial trouble they don't have no
money what's interesting that was March
of last year so the money dried up a
longest time ago
in March of 2021 2022
oh so that's this year
wait what year is this it's 2022 my
friend Oh I thought I thought we were in
20 35 months ago six months ago okay
okay so this is this is all this is a
house of cards situation okay you know
he's probably waiting for more investor
money to pay them off what do you call
that
when you use new investors money to pay
the previous investors yeah you call
that Hustler University you call that
being a [ __ ] top G dude no isn't that
a Ponzi scheme
uh it's I mean there's many terms I
think that's what a Ponzi scheme
describes some sort of Arrangement where
no I'm serious let me Google define
Ponzi scheme form of fraud in which
belief in the success of non-existent
Enterprises fostered by the payment of
quick returns to the first investor from
money invested by later investors
so if he's hoping for more investor
money to pay off
Sony music
maybe a misunderstanding but that maybe
that could that be a Ponzi scheme
hmm
I think
reasonably
colloquially colloquially
that's interesting isn't it
so they stopped paying him in March and
then Sony told triller well if you're
not paying us
we're going to terminate our deal and
you have to remove the songs from your
app seems reasonable right
direct quote from Sony Music said
trailer has historically failed to make
payments in a timely manner under the
agreement but its failures recently
escalated
triller then stopped paying the required
monthly payment altogether
after Sony attempted to secure the
overdue payments from triller Trailer
ghosted Sony
and they were forced to terminate the
partnership Sony music by the way it's a
big company right they probably have
good lawyers
uh yeah probably good oh yeah Sony have
you heard of Sony Music I'm not familiar
with that one no no
that's probably not a company to [ __ ]
with legally I mean there's three top
dogs in the music business is umg Sony
and Warner okay so that's probably not a
good idea to stop paying them huh yeah
probably not because they probably have
like insane at least uh good lawyers
just on retainer I would yeah right
probably I'm gonna have to pay them to
[ __ ] with them legally no
since the termination on August 8th oh
that was just oh [ __ ] this that was this
month so this is fresh
triller is still showcasing Sony Music
in their audio library now this is very
interesting
Sony told them August 8th yo we're
terminated the contract you guys haven't
paid us months
and then triller says well we're not
going to remove your music
which is called willful copyright
infringement now let's remember how this
all started
um trailer suing me for what
copyright infringement right
for reacting to a short clip of the
boxing match okay
then Sony
um they have a bunch of songs of Sony's
Sony told them to remove it they're
actually not doing it that's willful
copper infusion ugh it's just weird that
they would sue me for that hmm
and then committed themselves Sony
criticized triller for trumpeting its
explosive growth and acquisition of
platforms including Julius and fan Gage
while leaving Millions unpaid
during the exact same months that
triller was failing to make licensing
payments to Sony Music it went on a
purchasing spree
yep and this is just a few uh a few
weeks after the Timberland and swiss
beasts uh situation where they sued
triller for not paying for verses which
is that's right I'm never going to get
paid yeah that's a line bro yeah people
way bigger dogs way bigger amounts of
money yeah
I feel like he get Kavanaugh gives me
like the firefest guy it's like if I
just keep pushing and getting more money
and doing it's gonna work out somehow
but the man actually just doesn't have
he doesn't know how to run a business
the man actually has no discernible
Talent at all yeah I mean he was born
with the silver spoon in his mouth and
he's been able to
have some level of he's failed upwards
and um this proves it I mean this this
is
this is [ __ ] this might be criminal I
don't know
I think of him like Adam Sandler and
uncut gems just running from right yeah
but but but less likable more hidden
right right yeah possibly drunk driving
possibly
that is what he's that's one thing we
know he's good at driving drunk yeah
well he's not good at it because he
cracked he had a car
I would consider that part of that's
part was good at it he would have never
got caught oh
true but he got caught more of them
maybe bankrupt he's good at bankrupting
that that he's good he's got a lot of
experience he's got a proven track
record that he is good at yeah he can
hold a big check really good at that
yeah
novelty checks he knows handing those
out mm-hmm those Lett get cocked well
yep no he likes to watch his wife [ __ ]
other men but that's spec he's really
good that's speculating that speculation
Dan
yeah I think the only thing you can work
on is maybe like his Instagram game
patient
we need to put Mason in charge of Ryan
he needs a wardrobe uh rehaul man he
needs a makeup I think he needs to be
queer-eyed yeah exactly yeah I mean
he'll put it on credit right yeah there
you go
uh since the termination on August 8th
trailer still shows Sony music and the
most ironic turn of the century this
lawsuit states that trailers continued
use of Sony Music would constitute as
willful copyright infringement and of
course it was because they've
continually notified them
and broken the contract and yet they
continue to host their music
as a result of these efforts Sony Music
owns and or controls exclusive rights to
copyrighted music now we went on the
platform
they listed in the lawsuit some songs
that Sony owns Janis Joplin summertime
Run DMC It's Tricky Doja cats say so Lil
Nas X Old Town Road those are bangers uh
khalid's location and 24 gold mood and
countless other hits across Generations
so we went on the trailer app right
because we're like wow
surely
they want they must have removed it but
now because that's willful copyright
infringement I mean they were so quick
to sue me for copyright infringement
surely they have the utmost respect for
copyright right
and copyright holders four of the six
songs above are still on triller's app
uh Doja Cat Say It Ain't So little Nas X
Old Town Road
seems to be the only two that were
removed so far
yeah in the complaint there lists four
other artists they're all still there
only one of them Janice Joplin is a live
version so I don't know if that one
technically counts but even not counting
that one that means three of the six are
still there
yeah this is an interesting legal uh
approach I wonder what's his strategy on
this one
what's his strategy on this one
maybe he'll claim fair use
sure yeah that's fairies just play the
song
he'll cite my case it's transformative
you're honored how epic with that be
your honor they were clearly dancing to
the song
transformative experience of commentary
imagine they had to argue fair use and
use your case that would be epic
no I mean they're just there's no
they're gonna get sued in the ground
yeah they're still there's still there's
not even like plausible deniability here
it's like George is totally [ __ ] like
he's not even trying they're so bankrupt
I mean I've been calling this I called
this I said trailer is gonna be bankrupt
by the end of the year did I not say
that
you said it he probably did say at some
point I said it many times yeah
hold it I want to check audio audio
audio triller said that audio audio
audio
that's them right now
but I wonder if this is some kind of
strategy if Ryan's thinking like
he's almost got his head in the sand
maybe he's waiting for more investor
money
some sap [ __ ] loser who doesn't know
anything about I don't know how they're
gambling it all on uh skill house right
they think that's going to be a big hit
um
right because if he goes bankrupt it
looks like they spent about fifteen
thousand dollars making that movie so it
there is a decent chance that it makes
some money I don't know bro how much did
they lose last year 800 billion yeah it
was 800 million 800 billion these but
Ryan cabins
he lost 800 million of investors
now I just people always go you hear
people say this like rich people stay
Rich because they don't eat avocado
toast and they drive old cars and they
don't buy uh what rich people stay Rich
because money is [ __ ] easy to make
when you're rich these people are so
dumb they're giving Ryan Kavanaugh a
billion dollars rich people are not
smart because they're penny pinching or
they're not rich because they Penny
pitch they Rich because they're rich
it's [ __ ] these idiots lose money
like nothing I mean how dumb do you have
to be to give Ryan a billion dollars
yeah so I think I wonder if he's
thinking like if I could just hold out
for this movie or if I could just hold
out for the investor money I can pay
Sony
I can pay everyone we're gonna make it
I think he's thinking that
um
but it's not happening this is the fire
Fest of apps
I know you've already said this but I
don't know how people don't just do a
quick Google search like I'm looking
right now in your post from 2015
relativity media needs to pay 200
million in debt in less than a week
that's it well guess what don't even
blame us because guess what they're
doing it August 29th that's was it two
days ago
now it's 200 million raise no [ __ ]
way these people so no Falcons Capital
Financial they raised 200 million that's
what I'm saying smart rich people are
not smart this is evidence of it these
people are
criminally dumb
bro these guys right here what are you
guys this is propping up trailer what
there's got to be something going on
these people are not that dumb yeah I
feel like they're like dealing money
watching money or something who knows
who knows what's going on here and
there's no way Ryan's on charismatic ass
is you know Charming these guys there's
no way how could these guys be that dumb
how did this impossible is it possible
they work with his like Mom or Dad or
whoever
and his family is also in the business
what even if it's loaded how are you
even if that was just like a he was like
a a Serial entrepreneur or something he
wasn't even in the film industry right
his uncle's in the film industry oh it
was his uncle okay maybe like yeah
either way either way how many times
could you get ripped off because of you
know you know yeah even if you're rich
as [ __ ] I don't even think you're you're
not down to lose 200 million dollars
like yeah yeah I don't get it it just
keeps happening can you clip those
investors again
well that was Falcon Capital there's a
there's a few others let's see Clearview
Partners here time to invest if you're a
Chinese company from Shanghai well that
makes sense they don't know but again
you just Google his name it's not even
our website there's so much literature
about him
look at yourself
so he fights these people
and then we also have fubon Financial
holding Fubar Financial
um
oh my god dude if you actually want to
make something good he should make it
back from it appears to be another uh
people another Asian friend that's what
the marketing company that worked with
firefest did oh no way okay yeah oh it
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] uh [ __ ] Jerry did
that oh okay they're such skunks yeah
that's interesting like I'd be
interested to see how he does this [ __ ]
Jerry help them perpetuate this giant
fraud and then sold the documentary
rights of it yeah I know insane pretty
good right
so bro this is really blowing my mind
he just raised 200 million dollars
sir
what the [ __ ]
at least uh maybe you'll get paid now
yeah probably not they're still that's
not gonna even last them that long how
long is 200 million gonna let the guy
burned through 800 000 right yes the
lawsuits this month
oh my god dude oh I remember how they
were gonna do a merger and go public
that got canceled right right
also he's playing he really wants to go
public I don't know yeah on the IPO side
exec's reiterated that trailer is
expected to list on NASDAQ directly a
planned special perships acquisition
company merger previously fell through
under the ticker toys
so that fell through but they're
insisting that they will still be going
public on NASDAQ that's what he's
pushing for he wants public so he can
cash out pay all these people he just
wants a Payday dude
how is anyone
how is this working I'm just saying this
whole
this is I'm just speechless
yeah imagine what we could do with 200
million I'll make your money back
I'll go sell hot dogs and make more
money go sit up hot dog stands
everywhere 200 million I'll give you a
better return
fruit stands and hot dog stands that's
my idea
oh my God a chariot Charlie demilio
horror is this something he's working on
eight Charlie demilio movies eight
did you say eight eight that's correct
eight is this related to triller well we
have we don't even know related we don't
even know if she's a good actress wait
let's give us one see what the people
think
eight
so is this the problem where do you see
that
uh I I mean I don't know Ian just sent
this but I do remember reading that
Dixie was one of the creators that uh
Ryan signed up yeah I remember that um
this is Charlie though it says in the
article uh described as The Sixth Sense
meets get out by Ryan Cavanaugh oh my
God
there it is what right you are going on
what the [ __ ] is happening
can't wait
I can't wait for all eight
Lady Justice now thank you for the gift
of 50. appreciate it says in the article
uh Charlie said while the role will
certainly be challenging and push me to
learn to act
and become the character
well there you go to learn how to act
being in a movie to learn to act I hope
they all come together like the MCU in
the end they're like eight different
story lines that all line up
by the way I want to say Lady Justice I
know we just crossed over but 50 gifted
is massive that's so [ __ ] nice thank
you so much it's so nice to everyone who
keeps gifting Subs fantastic thank you
baby Justice yeah
oh that's the prince oh it's the prince
shut up
yes can we have 200 million
hey do you have 200 million dollars to
give us thank you for the gifted
200 million thank you for the gift give
me two hundred dollars
this is all just too much the fact that
he's still succeeding
this is the story of Ryan kavanagh's
life failing upwards he just got 200
million dollars he can't keep getting
away with it there's no way this company
is worth any money there you have nobody
on their social media their boxing
vertical has failed he's now trying to
make movies which he's historically felt
at that look horrible it doesn't make
any sense
nothing
I don't know what to make of all this
so there it is calf calf
feeling up ladies and gentlemen but like
you said maybe maybe the Silver Linings
that I get paid inshallah
alhamdulillah
time to pay Ryan the clock is ticking
are you sure his teeth are that yellow I
feel like they got yellower
photograph
that looks photography
I mean this
real life being captured
yeah so anyway that's it I think it's I
have a lot of other stuff to talk about
but uh
um it's getting late I guess we've been
going for a minute how long we've been
going for
oh we've been going for uh three hours
six minutes and 25 seconds sorry I was
distracted because I just noticed in
this deadline article I had pulled up I
just kind of passively scrolling down
top comment from Cav cap this is going
to be one of the best films ever made
and nothing will go bankrupt I promise
and Ryan is one of the best movie makers
ah let's go and that's from July 19th so
yeah exactly yeah that's been there I'll
go down with one under it go down
worst decision ever 50 ain't good enough
to act for horror I mean no height 50
but that voiceover sounded really bad
die
Moira
I think 50 is a bad guy once in a movie
and it was it was horrible I like him as
an artist but he's funny yeah he was in
that movie with Robert De Niro and Al
Pacino Zach might know what it well that
really highlighted his bad acting
okay now is this is this altered or is
this his teeth no this is from Google
that's altered what
cam yes it's too white what they made it
wait how's it altered they've whitened
it artificially I just dropped the real
one oh here's the room that one I see
let's take a look there's the original
okay
you pulling it up down
oh my God that can't be real yes
teeth look like candy corns he doesn't
brush them
don't go that close it doesn't look as
good close-up homie's got some
gingivitis dude he needs to see a
dentist right
is halitosis must be off the chain take
some of their your lawyer funds and go
see a dentist bro thank you Katie cat
meow thank you for the gifted five thank
you so much thank you God bless God
bless
Zach we are friends on Tick Tock Foodies
I know them
I'm sorry I said I was bricked up please
DM me back I love you
boy
what Foodies yeah I follow them on Tick
Tock but I have no idea check your DMs
what's in there
apparently some crazy [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
yeah so that's about it guys I don't
know what to say you know
it's [ __ ] incredible don't let any of
these dumb Financial gurus tell you that
rich people stay Rich because of this
that's all [ __ ] you think rich
people care about driving an old car the
amount of money it costs to get a new
car is like negligible when you're a
millionaire it doesn't matter
and and when you're as rich as Ryan
Kavanaugh apparently it doesn't even
[ __ ] matter if you're competent in
the least bit people just give you money
uh they're not going to toski 20 thank
you it's my birthday today could I
please get a shout out for my dirty 30.
[Applause]
happy Thursday so they're over 25. way
over bro
damaged goods man yeah way past their
Prime
thank you brother or sister nothing with
the prime or non-specified gender
foreign
what do you make of this Dan you're a
smart guy how is it that he got 200
million I just don't I literally don't
understand it I'm I'm flabbergasted by
that I'm I'm offended
go ahead Dan
what are you offended by I'm just
kidding okay
oh what do you think Abe I'm not smart
well I I'm asking you what you think oh
that's so sweet I don't know I don't
know anything about this I was a [ __ ]
idiot you don't know anything dumbass
I mean I who knows again he famously is
good at this right like it unironically
Ryan Kavanaugh is his one skill is
apparently fleecing money out of people
it doesn't make sense when like you're
famous for going I think he talks a good
he talks a big talk and he probably
convinces them that uh tiktok is
um is declining somehow or or in danger
of uh being banned and that triller is
in a good position as you know the
second
company when it comes to that type of
content to move in on that market space
I mean that I don't know what else he
could really pitch to them they don't
have anything else they don't have a big
user base I guess they have the
infrastructure like it it is an app that
works somewhat one of the only way two
of those investors were Chinese right
two of them were well one was Chinese
for sure the other I saw another one
with I don't know if it was Chinese
exactly it could be I'm Hong Kong or who
knows I don't know but the only way he
could convince these people to give him
money in my opinion
if he's like I have Intel that tick
tock's about to get
right [ __ ] that's the only angle that
makes any sense to me yeah he's got to
be like dude you can take a gamble on me
give me a hundred million right I know
tick tock's about to go down that's
gonna be worth a billion dollars easy or
he could be showing them the Indian
charts like in India I mean um because
they're number one in India because
there's no Tick Tock because okay they
have a pool there in India that is
interesting who wants to lose some money
today so so okay that is interesting
aspect so you are smart you
that's a great point I should ask you
baby thanks man yeah I regret asking you
Dan they're the biggest in parts of
Africa too I've seen how do you see that
well can we see where it's popular
well it's on on the CEO's Instagram
I saw he was tweeting out about it here
not to be a hater but I don't think
there's like
top dollar there
yeah well I think some ads and stuff do
you guys know how some app apps
sometimes pushes you to like review that
I bet if we were to go on trailer and
actually look into it that they push
like the rate rate the app super much to
the users all the time just to push the
review numbers up and then they like uh
show it to investors
this was from February 2020 so yeah this
is not
do you have a v should we kill me from a
VPN and see if they rank still this is
Nigeria which is famously uh one of the
best markets for advertising dollars
Nigeria ladies and gentlemen
absolutely do they even have ads on
trailer yet
I don't know they should do a tick tock
I haven't used it enough well yeah tip
talk is like established now because no
every I get it to add like every three
tick tocks these days it's insane it
definitely increased big time good for
them I love Tick Tock huge supporter
until until they go out of business
I'm extremely proud of our team for
getting triller to number one most
downloaded app in Nigeria
yeah and Mark when I used to work in
marketing Nigeria is like a weird
country because
for whatever reason it's like the stats
were always funky there like it was
super cheap to advertise there the the
click-through was insane but like
obviously nobody ever spent money
um so get this on every single trailer
video there's a little link
uh that shows merch you click merch and
it's triller merch on every video
and it's four of every Thriller every
Thriller video yep it's in the top left
corner on every trailer okay
um and it leads to a night of r b
Omarion versus Mario
I'm guessing this is the versus series
that they're doing but you can buy a
Mario
uh sure this is Let Me Love You for
those who don't remember Mario sung the
song Let Me Love You in like 2004
and Omarion
um or
a very popular artists from the early
2000s what are you and
I'm just saying it's funny every single
every single uh Thriller video leads to
that
I think it's funny they're trying to
sell merge that's not a very good
business strategy nobody folks we're
Thriller
um
that's incredible yeah so
congratulations to triller for being
number one in Nigeria
that's huge
foreign
right in 20 two years in the in February
of 2020. they were also topping a bunch
of other countries that I think that's
when Tick Tock was having trouble and
everyone's afraid yeah I remember that
they were top top in the US too at some
point dude there was even for a minute a
time when new people couldn't download
Tick Tock like they straight up said
you can't yeah Trump was on the verge of
banning it I mean there was like
that's the thing right I think I think
triller is only surviving now as sort of
a an after Ripple of that moment in
mid-2020 when they genuinely were
positioned to maybe become a huge thing
because if trailer got banned or if Tick
Tock got banned they were already there
it already existed it had a similar
algorithm a similar format and they were
definitely in a position to to swoop in
and pick all that up but that didn't end
up happening and now
they're just floundering because their
app [ __ ] sucks yeah I think this guy
was Doom said it it's the bot Nations
like but no at the time people were
actually downloading yeah and also this
was following like Charlie demilio and
Dixie and I believe Bryce Hall as well
yeah they were getting big names for a
minute there
they were all saying they're moving a
trailer because of
whatever reason they're paid to say it
allegedly ah this is so nuts this is all
so wild I'm in your walls Ethan thank
you Sophia
thank you for the gifted
uh for Sam's Jeep fun oh my God 20 for
jams Sam's Jeep fun
did you check your DMs with foodie Zach
uh I did I didn't see any I saw them
saying I apologize for saying that you
were bricked up what the [ __ ] is
happening this guy's having a one-man
drama with you they probably like
commented on that on one of your videos
or something oh wait no no I'm sorry
April 9th bro trying to get me bricked
up
because they message me you Legend I
said no you and they said bro trying to
get me bricked up
and he thinks that he went to you were
offended yeah I'm not offended I just
don't know how to respond to that
what do you want me to say no comment
sorry I just gave you a boner like you
know
ha ha good [ __ ]
oh Eric this guy Eric said I made an 80s
synth pop cover of passports
do you want to hear it Eric send it to
Ahmad I definitely want to hear it
sure
100
yeah so versus assuming I know
everybody's suing him
uh well there you have it um Brian
Kavanaugh ladies and gentlemen
great guy
some would say a self-made man thank you
some would say
one of the greatest entrepreneurs
somewhat not also some would not I would
be one of them
drive angry some would say he runs a
Ponzi scheme drive angry but they
reached someone who said that would
retract it
his ex-business partner via variety
retracted that statement so I guess they
wouldn't say that now
but they did say it in a uh they said it
when they accidentally filed a lawsuit
yeah right under the threat of perjury
have an inappropriate relationship with
a four-year-old Natalie Portman that's
weird I forgot about that one
some would say it's a force of nature
you know I'm not going to say Harvey
Weinstein yeah you got sued because
obviously this has been a stressful
thing for you
um even if we have gotten a lot of
content out of it but
I can say that
we were blessed by the person that
decided to go after you just being the
most embarrassing
like lol cow of a human being you could
possibly imagine it's endless with this
guy well and the truth is that like it
could have just been some boring ass
executive that like wasn't fun to make
fun of you know what I mean like we
truly are blessed by Ryan
innocent and truth I don't think anyone
else would sue me for something right it
takes somebody a little while to to get
this upset about it yeah
food English wine sorry foodie's
commented Zach he says Woodies so
shout out Foodies
Nathan says Zach I'm not sir you
definitely Breaking Me Up
[Laughter]
all right well that's about it eh
said it all is that it all in our best
regards to Ryan Kavanaugh who has
uh let me just Google uh let me check
the timer
type Ryan Kavanaugh
find the website there it is
so he has 15 days 28 minutes 20 seconds
yes yes yes yes which we will be
donating to Habitat Humanity
uh if he ever gives it to us which he
failed to do by the way also what what
all right enough guys uh I guess
tomorrow is Thursday so
leftovers uh tomorrow
[Laughter]
looking forward to that always a good
time with our dear friend Hassan we got
some good [ __ ] in the dock for tomorrow
too yeah that's yeah really good [ __ ]
can I give like a tiny preview of
something that I think is going to be
really fun of course the show is getting
so bomb oh thank you I enjoy I've been
enjoying it a lot it's like slowly
getting better and better and funnier
that's nice someone I'm sorry go ahead
no you go ahead no I insist no you no
you're gonna say something as someone
who's not traditionally into politics
I'm loving it yeah oh that's so nice I
feel like it's more about the memes yes
it really is
just that's nice to hear yeah I've been
really enjoying the show lately so I'm
happy to hear you guys say that it has
been fun
okay don't show it quite yet because I
don't I just I just wanna I'm gonna full
screen it again and I just want the just
the image
did we see if this gets claimed can we
listen to it
I don't believe we checked it yet well I
wasn't gonna play it I know but I want
to listen to it tomorrow oh well yeah
we'll check to make sure that yeah
and I'm gonna get pissed off about it
wait his band name is Tim cast
he says Tim cast
Dash only ever wanted
dude there's nothing more punk rock than
[ __ ] uh
being against gay rights
trans rights and being a conservative
shipbag
punk rock was famously about uh
maintaining the status being a con
having conservative values good family
values damn it well he's a traditional
liberal or has he abandoned saying that
I don't think for a while there he was
like I'm a classical liberal yeah I
think it's dropped
um
wait that monkey's sucking himself off
is a real nft
yep oh let's buy it it doesn't have any
purchasing history
um how much is it worth they have two
ethereum total value okay all right not
bad not too bad yeah ah all right guys
we'll see you tomorrow morning thank you
so much for watching shout out Ryan
Cavanaugh
shout out Steve will do it my goodness
that man jerked off his dog
oh here's the synth cover okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
to America I'm fighting
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
then it's the full version
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just such a hit
wow remember guys if you want a sleeping
supplements you can get 50 off at nelk
uh Fitness with code Bill Cosby ladies
and gentlemen
so
love that that really seems like
one of you like that's one of your jokes
like that's something that you would say
but it's just not a joke that's actually
a thing that's actually their code
insane alrighty guys see you tomorrow
morning
thanks for watching everybody
love it love it
see ya oh God bye-bye
[Music]
foreign